I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello, hello everyone. Welcome to Sobre.
我是詹妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了这个终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好，大家好。欢迎来到 Sobre。
Yes, it is season six, episode 15 written by Jennifer Salotta, known to us as Jen Salotta, and directed by John Krasinski. Yes, known to us as JK. Oh my gosh. John, great job. I loved this episode. I did too.
没错，这是第六季第 15 集，由詹妮弗·萨洛塔编剧（我们叫她珍·萨洛塔），约翰·卡拉辛斯基执导。是的，我们叫他 JK。哦，天哪。约翰，干得漂亮。我很喜欢这一集。我也是。
It was one of those sleeper ones that I hadn't watched in years. That I had forgotten about. Yeah, and I was cracking up. Oh my gosh, so many memories flooded back for me. All those daycare scenes. Oh, they were so good. Oh my gosh. And they're way to talk about them.
这是一集我多年没看过、差点忘了的“遗珠”之一。是的，我当时笑得不行。天哪，好多回忆一下子涌上心头。所有那些托儿所的场景。哦，它们太棒了。天哪。而且他们谈论这些的方式。
I can't wait to talk about them. And there's even more in the shooting draft that didn't make it in. So we're going to share it all with you. Here's a summary. Dundermiflin has officially been bought by a new company. Saber, Gabe Lewis, the new director of sales arrives in Scranton and brings with him a list of changes and new company policies that do not sit well with Michael. Michael seeks advice from a very unemployed David Wallace. Meanwhile, Pam and Jim tour
我已经迫不及待想聊聊它们了。拍摄剧本里还有更多没有播出的内容。所以我们要把这些都分享给你们。以下是剧情简介。邓德米夫林正式被一家新公司收购了。Saber，新任销售总监盖布·刘易斯抵达斯克兰顿，并带来了一系列让迈克尔非常不满的变革和新公司政策。迈克尔向一个彻底失业的大卫·华莱士寻求建议。与此同时，帕姆和吉姆参观了
a daycare center and Aaron and Andy wait for the other to make a move. It is the most awkward courtship of two people. I was yelling at the TV screen. I was like, one of you just asked the other one out. They're making me crazy. We have so much stuff to share in this episode. I mean, I hope we can get through it all. We better get to it, but before we do, folks, I want you to know, Jenna's wearing a
一家托儿所，而艾琳和安迪则在等待对方采取行动。这是两个最尴尬的追求。我当时对着电视屏幕大喊。我说，你们两个随便谁去约对方出去不就好了。他们把我逼疯了。我们在这一集里有太多东西要分享了。我的意思是，我希望我们能把所有内容都讲完。我们最好抓紧时间，但在开始之前，各位，我想让你们知道，詹娜今天在西装翻领上戴了一朵
poofy flower on her lapel today. Okay. I'm trying this. This is your book look. Oh, and our book is coming out in two weeks in two weeks. Our book is launching into the world. And we need a bunch of outfits, Angela, you know, I've been spending weeks and weeks curating outfits because I am not naturally gifted in that area. I never want you to stop trying to put together outfits because now every day and I'm talking
蓬松的花。好吧。我正在尝试这个。这是你的书的造型。哦，我们的书两周后就要出了，两周后。我们的书就要向全世界发布了。我们需要准备一堆服装，安吉拉，你知道的，我花了好几周时间精心挑选服装，因为我在那方面实在没有天赋。我希望你永远不要停止尝试搭配服装，因为现在每天——我是说几乎每天
I mean almost every day. I get a picture of you in front of your closet and you're like what about this? I know and so here's the problem I'm having every day, I get a picture of you in front of your closet. And you're like, what about this? I know. And so here's the problem I'm having. I declared that I was going to wear fakey flowers. You sure did. You made a big declaration. And it's not working.
——我都会收到一张你站在衣柜前的照片，然后你会说：“这个怎么样？”我知道，所以这就是我每天遇到的问题，我都会收到一张你站在衣柜前的照片。然后你会说：“这个怎么样？”我知道，所以这就是我遇到的问题。我宣称我要戴假花。你确实这么说了。你发表了庄严的声明。但它不管用。
I'm wearing one today because I wanted you to see. Hear me out. I'm going to stand up. Well, I want you to see what I think is happening here. And I know it's the striped shirt, but I think it's the fakey Well, I want you to see what I think is happening here. And I know it's the striped shirt, but I think it's the fakie flower too. Are you ready? Yeah. What does this remind you of? Oh, yeah. You look like a French mine. I look like a Parisian mine. You do wait. I need a picture of you doing that. Oh my gosh. All right. well, we're very excited.
我今天戴了一朵，是因为我想让你看看。听我解释。我要站起来。好吧，我想让你看看我觉得这里发生了什么。我知道是这件条纹衬衫的原因，但我认为也是这朵假花的问题。好吧，我想让你看看我觉得这里发生了什么。我知道是这件条纹衬衫的原因，但我也觉得是这朵假花的问题。准备好了吗？嗯。这让你想起了什么？哦，是的。你看起来像个法国哑剧演员。我看起来像个巴黎哑剧演员。你确实——等一下。我得拍一张你做这个动作的照片。天哪。好吧，我们非常兴奋。
Our book is coming out in two weeks. We can't believe it. I can't promise I'm going to wear a fakey flower every one. No, I'm sorry to disappoint. I'm still trying. You got to have one, Jenna. Just one. I'll work on it.
我们的书两周后就要出版了。我们简直不敢相信。我不能保证我每次都会戴假花。不，我很抱歉让你们失望了。我还在努力。你得戴一个，詹娜。就一个。我会努力的。
All right. Let's get into fast facts. Fast fact number one, John Krasinski directed this episode. My gosh! We had a fan question from Alice R. in Italy. No. How was it seeing John Krasinski on the other side of the camera as director? He did an amazing job.
好吧。让我们进入快速事实环节。快速事实一，约翰·卡拉辛斯基导演了这一集。天哪！我们收到了来自意大利的爱丽丝·R 的粉丝提问。不。作为导演，看到约翰·卡拉辛斯基在镜头另一端是什么感觉？他做得太棒了。
He sure did. He was just like a natural. He really was. It was a total pleasure. It was always tricky what was it gonna be like when one of our castmates stepped into directing, particularly because they had to be on both sides of the camera. Like logistically, how does that work? Right. And John was your major scene partner.
他确实做到了。他表现得就像个天生的导演。真的。这绝对是一种享受。当我们的演员之一开始涉足导演工作时，事情总是很棘手，特别是他们必须兼顾镜头的两端。比如在后勤上，这是怎么运作的？对的。而约翰是你的主要对手戏演员。
He was. It was so crazy how we could do scenes together and he would be completely in character as Jim. I felt like I was talking to Jim, but then we would cut and he would have simultaneously observed things and would have notes. I don't know how he did, I don't know how your brain does that. My brain doesn't do that. Some people have that brain though.
他是。太疯狂了，我们怎么能一起演戏，而他还能完全沉浸在吉姆的角色中。我觉得我是在跟吉姆说话，但随后我们会喊停，而他却能同时观察到各种情况并给出意见。我不知道他是怎么做到的，我不知道你的大脑是怎么运作的。我的大脑可做不到。不过有些人确实有那样的大脑。
They just compartmentalize it and then they know how to like, I'm sort of a one trick pony. I know, I like to be doing the one thing, I'm just thinking. I'm real good at the one thing at one time. Well, we reached out to John, and he's off right now filming season three of Jack Ryan, but he sent in some audio clips,
他们只是把它模块化，然后他们就知道如何——我有点像只会一招的马。我知道，我喜欢做好一件事，我只想着这件事。我真的很擅长在同一时间做好一件事。好吧，我们联系了约翰，他现在正在外面拍摄《杰克·莱恩》第三季，但他发来了一些音频剪辑，
and we're so excited to share them with you. First off, he talked about what it was like to direct the show. Hi guys, wait a minute, how are you on Saber already? That means that it is season 6? You're in the season 6? No, slow down. We need more of this podcast. The world needs more of this podcast. For the love of Pete, that's all I have to say about that.
我们非常高兴能与大家分享。首先，他谈到了导演这部剧的感受。嗨，等一下，你们怎么就已经聊到 Saber 了？这说明已经是第六季了吗？你们已经到第六季了？不，慢点。我们需要更多的这个播客。世界需要更多的这个播客。看在老天的份上，这就是我想说的全部。
What was it like directing Saber? It was a dream. It was absolutely everything you would wish directing a show like this would be I personally was terrified because I had to direct all of you. I remember being really, really nervous about that that you were my co-workers, but you were my closest friends. You were my family. And here I was thinking I had the audacity to tell you what to do. Which incidentally, I don't think I did once. I'm not sure I gave one acting note to any of you, because I was just in awe watching, sitting back and watching.
导演 Saber 是什么感觉？这简直是个梦想。这绝对是你对导演这样一部剧的所有美好期望。我个人当时吓坏了，因为我得导演你们所有人。我记得对此感到非——常紧张，因为你们既是我的同事，但也是我最亲密的朋友。你们是我的家人。而我却在这里自以为是，居然有胆量告诉你们该做什么。顺便说一句，我觉得我一次也没这么做过。我不确定我有没有给你们任何人提供过表演方面的建议，因为我只是坐在后面，满怀敬畏地看着你们。
Which really was one of the most special parts about directing the show, was getting to see through a totally unique lens of being behind these monitors. The magic that every single one of you brought to each and every moment, whether it was a joke or whether it was an emotional beat, everyone was just so good at what they did. And of course, as an actor, I always used to love watching everybody play in these scenes, but there were so many scenes that I wasn't a part of. So, you know, getting to, in saver, getting to be a part of the hot tub scene with Michael and David Wallace.
这真的是导演这部剧最特别的部分之一，那就是通过一个完全独特的镜头——坐在监视器后面的视角——去见证你们每个人为每一个时刻带来的魔力，无论是笑点还是情感节点，每个人都把自己所做的事情做得极其出色。当然，作为一个演员，我以前总是喜欢看大家在这些场景里表演，但有很多场景我并没有参与。所以，你知道的，在 Saber 这一集中，能够参与迈克尔和大卫·华莱士的热水浴缸场景，
At the end of the day, I think that directing that episode was a much bigger deal than I even understood or imagined then in that moment. Because the truth is directing is terrifying. As I told you, I was very nervous to do it on this show. And honestly, if it hadn't been for this episode being such an amazing experience surrounded by such hugely supportive crew members, cast members, producers, everyone, I don't know that I ever would have done it again. Truly. I mean, I think it was something that I was really excited to experiment with on our show, but never thought that I'd go
归根结底，我认为导演那一集是一件比我当时所能理解或想象的还要重大得多的事情。因为事实是，导演工作太可怕了。正如我告诉过你的，我在这个节目里做这件事时非常紧张。老实说，如果不是因为这一集是一次如此美妙的经历，周围有如此巨大支持的剧组成员、演员、制作人、所有人，我不知道我是否还会再做一次。真的。我的意思是，我认为这是一件让我非常兴奋地在我们的节目中进行尝试的事情，但从未想过会尝试去
much further than that in trying to direct anything else. Can you imagine? Oh, man, could you imagine if he didn't keep directing, he's so good. I know. I just love that John got to have this experience on our show for the first time, because you and I know how loving and supportive everyone was. This was true for other people as well. I mean, our editor, Claire Scanlon,
导演任何其他东西。你能想象吗？哦，天哪，你能想象如果他没有继续导演吗，他太棒了。我知道。我只是很高兴约翰能在我们的节目中第一次有这样的经历，因为你我都知大家是多么充满爱意和支持。这对其他人来说也是一样的。我的意思是，我们的剪辑师克莱尔·斯坎伦，
has a very successful directing career in television. That started with the office. That was because Greg was very encouraging of having different department heads step into that role of director to step out of what they were doing and try this new thing in a really supportive environment. I feel like it launched the directing careers of many people. Randall Einnhorn, our cinematographer. Matt Sone.
在电视界拥有非常成功的导演生涯。那正是从《办公室》开始的。那是因为格雷格非常鼓励不同的部门负责人涉足导演角色，让他们走出自己原本的工作，在一个非常支持的环境中尝试这个新事物。我觉得这开启了许多人的导演生涯。兰德尔·艾因霍恩，我们的摄影师。马特·索恩。
Yes, so many. And, by the way, the writer of this episode, Jen Salotta. Yeah. I was just watching television the other day, I was watching Abad Elementary, and she directed the episode. I was like, oh my gosh! Yeah. Jens!
是的，有太多人了。顺便说一句，这一集的编剧，珍·萨洛塔。是的。我前几天还在看电视，我在看《小学风云》，她就是那集的导演。当时我就想，哦，天哪！是的。珍！
So many people. Well, listen, speaking of Jens Salotta, there is a great interview with her and John over on OfficeTellie.com for this episode. I'll share some of what they talked about as we go along, but one of the things that it included were interviews with cast members about John's directing. Oh, really? Yes. So I'm going to tell you what people said. All right.
太多人了。好吧，听着，说到珍·萨洛塔，OfficeTellie.com 上有一篇关于她和约翰的精彩采访。随着节目的进行，我会分享一些他们谈论的内容，其中之一就是对演员们关于约翰导演工作的采访。哦，真的吗？是的。所以我要告诉你们大家是怎么说的。好的。
Ellie said, John made me feel confident, yet calm, and also made me laugh throughout the entire week. If it isn't too weird a thing to say, I feel like he took very good care of us. Mm-hmm. Brian said he was bold, which I thought was cool. He wanted characters to try new things. Kate said, John was a very thoughtful director who created a great tone on set. He really did his homework on all levels.
埃莉说，约翰让我感到自信而平静，也让我在一周的拍摄中一直开怀大笑。如果这样说不太奇怪的话，我觉得他把我们照顾得非常好。嗯哼。布莱恩说他很大胆，我觉得这很酷。他希望角色尝试新事物。凯特说，约翰是一位非常体贴的导演，他在片场营造了很好的氛围。他在各个层面都做了很多功课。
He took his job very seriously, but not himself. Like you didn't take himself seriously. That's John. And then Creed said, which one's John? Oh my gosh, Creed. It's so perfect. So perfect. Alright, fast fact number two, I'll have you know this was not John's directorial debut.
他非常认真地对待自己的工作，但并不把自己太当回事。就像他没把自己当回事一样。这就是约翰。然后克里德说，哪个是约翰？哦，天哪，克里德。太完美了。太完美了。好吧，快速事实二，我要告诉你们，这并不是约翰的导演处女作。
What was? So this might have been the thing that inspired him to keep directing, but it was not his debut. He had written, produced, and directed the film, brief interviews with hideous men based on the short story collection by David Foster Wallace. I remember this from the time we did the pilot. John loved this book. And I guess he purchased the rights to the book with his first paycheck from the office. He had always wanted to adapt it. He's so smart like that. I know. He's such a forward thinker. He is. Originally, he was just going to write and produce the film. Did you know John majored in screenwriting at Brown University? I didn't know that. I know. Yeah. So he majored in screenwriting, not acting.
那是什么？所以这可能是激发他继续导演的东西，但这不是他的处女作。他曾编剧、制作并导演了电影《与难看男人的短暂访谈》，该片改编自大卫·福斯特·华莱士的短篇小说集。从我们拍试播集的时候起我就记得这件事。约翰很喜欢这本书。我猜他是用拍《办公室》的第一笔片酬买下这本书的版权的。他一直想把它改编成电影。他就是这么聪明。我知道。他是个很有远见的人。他是的。最初，他只是想编写和制作这部电影。你知道约翰在布朗大学主修编剧吗？我不知道。我知道。是的。所以他主修的是编剧，而不是表演。
Writing was really his first love. So anyway, he had the rights, but he couldn't find a director. And I guess it was Rain Wilson, who said to him on set one day, why don't you just direct it yourself? That sounds like rain too. Yeah. Rain is very much the person that's like, why don't you just do it? You're like, oh, you do it. too. Yeah, rain. It's very much the person that's like, why don't you just do it? You're like, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, movie called The Hollers, and of course, a quiet place. Which I watched on the plane was crazy.
写作真的是他的初恋。总之，他拥有版权，但他找不到导演。我猜是雷恩·威尔逊有一天在片场对他说：“你为什么不自己导演呢？”听起来也很像雷恩。是的。雷恩就是那种会说“你为什么不自己干呢？”的人，而你会说：“哦，你自己干吧。电影叫《霍勒斯》，当然还有《寂静之地》。我在飞机上看了这部电影，太疯狂了。
Oh, lady. Oh, lady. John, did you yell out? Yes, I was like, I'm sure people thought I was crazy. Oh my gosh. Well, you know, his next directorial project is a film called If, and he's reuniting with Steve Carell. Steve's gonna be in it. Oh my gosh, we have to go see that together. Let's do it.
哦，天哪。哦，天哪。约翰，你当时喊出来了吗？是的，我想当时人们一定觉得我疯了。哦，天哪。好吧，你知道的，他的下一个导演项目是一部名为《分秒必争》的电影，他将与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔再次合作。史蒂夫会参演。哦，天哪，我们得一起去看。我们去吧。
So one more thing I wanna point out before we move on to FastFact number three, because FastFact number three is all Angela. Oh no. So I'm squeezing a little extra information into my FastFact two. Squeeze it. Which is that we need to point out
在我们进入快速事实三之前，我还要指出一件事，因为快速事实三完全属于安吉拉。哦，不。所以我把一点额外的信息塞进我的快速事实二里。塞进去吧。那就是我们需要指出，
what a very big deal it was for John to direct this particular episode because he had to establish two new major characters in the show. Kathy Bates is Joe Bennett and Zach Woods as Gabe Lewis. And he directed Christians later. So this was not just a regular episode of the office.
约翰导演这一集是一件非常重大的事情，因为他必须在剧中建立两个新的主要角色。凯西·贝茨饰演乔·贝内特，扎克·伍兹饰演盖布·刘易斯。而且他后来还导演了克里斯蒂安。所以这不仅仅是《办公室》里普通的一集。
He had to do the whole saber video. Oh my gosh, I didn't even think about that. He had to start a whole new company. He had to play a established saber. Well, it's a big episode to make your directorial debut. My lord. Well, John talked a little bit about it. Here we go. Introducing Kathy Bates, which was so mind blowing.
他必须完成整段 Saber 视频。哦，天哪，我甚至都没想到这一点。他必须建立一整家新公司。他必须引入建立 Saber。好吧，作为导演处女作，这一集可真够分量的。天哪。好吧，约翰谈到了这一点。我们听听。介绍凯西·贝茨，这简直太让人震撼了。
The Kathy Bates was not only on our show, but I was her first experience as a director, and for that I will always be a polygetic, too. But I remember introducing that character and knowing that, I don't know, feeling a big responsibility that that character was going to be a big part of the show and bringing along with her was Zach Woods, who I remember from the moment we shot his first stuff, the whole water bottle.
凯西·贝茨不仅出现在我们的节目中，而且我是她作为导演的第一段经历，为此我将永远向她道歉。但我记得在介绍那个角色时，我有一种……我不知道，感受到了一种重大的责任，因为那个角色将是该剧的重要组成部分，随之而来的是扎克·伍兹，我记得从我们拍摄他第一场戏的那一刻起，就是那个水瓶的故事线，
Storyline, he was just so unbelievably funny. He was so reserved in this brand new instrument that we had to play with on the show. A totally different character than anybody else. And yet, whenever he spoke, you couldn't take your eyes off him. He was always so, so funny. And I just remember with the big story changes that were happening in the show, I was so nervous to be the one to introduce those two characters. And then in the end, I don't know, feel somewhat honored to have been, to have been a part of it. I think those guys were lucky to have John as a director. He's so personable. He puts you so at ease. I mean, listen, all of our directors
他真的是不可思议地搞笑。他在我们必须在这部剧中使用的这个全新乐器中表现得如此克制。一个与其他任何人都完全不同的角色。然而，每当他开口说话，你就无法将视线从他身上移开。他总是那么、那么搞笑。我只记得随着剧中重大剧情的变化，作为介绍这两个角色的人，我感到非常紧张。最后，我不知道，能参与其中多少感到有些荣幸。我想那些家伙能有约翰做导演真是太幸运了。他太有亲和力了。他让你感到非常自在。我的意思是，听着，我们所有的导演
have a place in my heart. They're all great. But John really does have a gift at like walking into a room and just putting everyone like out of their heads. Do you know what I mean? He's a good connector. He is. He is. Good at connecting instantly. All right, Angela, it's you. It's FastFact 3. What do you got for me? Okay, here you go. FastFact number 3 is courtesy of Joya Balfour. Oh, who, as you guys know, worked for NBC Digital. She shared with us that NBC did an entire website for Saber. The site featured a bio on CEO Joe Bennett, the full Christian Slater video, a section with a company overview, plus it featured all of Sobre's, sobre, oh my god, I'm doing it.
在我心中都有一个位置。他们都很棒。但约翰确实有一种天赋，那就是走进一个房间，就能让所有人都放松下来。你知道我的意思吗？他很擅长建立连接。他是的。他是。很擅长瞬间建立连接。好了，安吉拉，轮到你了。这是快速事实三。你给我准备了什么？好吧，给你。快速事实三由乔亚·巴尔福提供。哦，大家知道，她曾在 NBC Digital 工作。她跟我们分享说，NBC 专门为 Saber 做了一个整个网站。该网站登载了首席执行官乔·贝内特的个人简介、完整的克里斯蒂安·斯莱特视频、带有公司概况的板块，此外还展示了 Sobre 的所有、sobre，哦，天哪，我又说错了。
Plus it featured all of Sabers printer products, a Q&A with Kelly Kapoor in an article titled, Printing All Colors. And my favorite section was an employee blog by scranton accountant Oscar Martinez. And the blog was titled, there's no accounting for taste. What? Yeah. And here were a few of his blogs he posted. One was titled, Winter Woe. The next one was titled, Music Makes the People Come Together.
此外，它还展示了 Saber 的所有打印机产品、与凯莉·卡普尔的问答以及一篇题为《打印所有颜色》的文章。我最喜欢的板块是斯克兰顿会计奥斯卡·马丁内斯的员工博客。博客的标题是“品味无可厚非”。什么？是的。以下是他发布的一些博客。一篇题为《冬日苦恼》。下一篇题为《音乐让人们聚在一起》。
And annoys me at the office. Oh my gosh. Lastly, he wrote a blog called A Different Voice. Joy found an archive of the website. The video's not on it, but some of the different elements are, I'll share in stories, it is hilarious. Oh my gosh. I know.
并且在办公室里惹恼我。哦，天哪。最后，他写了一篇名为《不同的声音》的博客。乔亚找到了该网站的存档。视频不在上面，但一些不同的元素还在，我会在快拍中分享，太搞笑了。哦，天哪。我知道。
I didn't know any of that stuff. I feel like NBC.com, like we've talked about it. They were just sort of ahead of the curve. Yeah. Another thing happening online at this time was a lot of people were very sad to see David Wallace go. And a save Wallace campaign started online. There was even a contest on officetally.com
我根本不知道这些东西。我觉得 NBC.com，就像我们讨论过的那样。他们当时就是走在了时代的前沿。是的。当时网络上发生的另一件事是，很多人对大卫·华莱士的离开感到非常难过。网上发起了一场“拯救华莱士”的活动。officetally.com 上甚至还举办了一场比赛，
where you could make a save Wallace icon. And a bunch of the icons are still up there. I'll put a few in stories. No way. Mm-hmm. Wow. But yeah, this was a huge episode. We're finally seeing Saber. So NBC really went all out.
你可以制作一个“拯救华莱士”的图标。现在上面还有一堆图标。我会把几个放到快拍里。真的吗？嗯哼。哇。但是的，这是一集非常重要的剧集。我们终于看到 Saber 了。所以 NBC 确实全力以赴了。
They were clearly excited about their Thursday night lineup this week because you know our favorite announcer, a guy. Uh-huh. He came back and they did a trailer. Here's the trailer that ran the week's going on. Well, you're not alone. And here's what to expect when Jen hooks is on 30 Rock. This show will have laughter. Cheers. Infections caused by Jacuzzi Water.
他们显然对这周的周四晚间阵容感到兴奋，因为你知道我们最喜欢的播音员，那个家伙。嗯哼。他回来了，他们还制作了一个预告片。这是当周播出的预告片。好吧，你并不孤单。以下是珍·霍克斯参加《我为喜剧狂》时可以期待的内容。这个节目会有欢笑。欢呼。由按摩浴缸水引起的感染。
Yep, the comedy's new this Thursday on NBC. Yep, the comedy's new. I want John to do an impression of that guy. Yeah, right. Me too. Oh, well, that was wonderful, Angela. Oh, you're welcome. You know, I've said before, I think you could always do FastFact 3 if you won. Okay. Happy to give it away. Happy to give away something you created for yourself. something you created for yourself. Something I didn't think about on episode one was that there would be let's see 600 fast facts that I'd have to come up with.
是的，本周四 NBC 将推出全新喜剧。是的，全新喜剧。我希望约翰模仿那个家伙。对吧。我也是。哦，好吧，那太棒了，安吉拉。哦，不客气。你知道的，我以前说过，如果你愿意，你随时可以做快速事实三。好吧。很高兴把它让出去。很高兴让出你自己创作的东西。我第一集时没想到会有 600 个快速事实需要我想出来。
But by episode 115 not as easy as it used to be. I am here for you any time. You need a fast-fact assist. Thank you lady. You're welcome. Let's take a break and then we'll be back to break down Sobri. Let's see how Michael opens a box, you guys. All right, this episode starts with Michael who is so excited because they have received a huge large box from Sobre. Their new owners. Uh-huh, and he asked Aaron to scissor him. Right.
但到了第 115 集，就没以前那么容易了。随时欢迎找我。你需要快速事实协助。谢谢你，亲爱的。不客气。我们休息一下，然后回来剖析 Sobri。让我们看看迈克尔是怎么开箱的，伙计们。好了，这一集从迈克尔开始，他兴奋极了，因为他们收到了一个来自 Sobre 的巨大包裹。他们的新老板。嗯哼，他让艾琳用剪刀伺候他。对的。
Which means to, I guess, toss him scissors from across the room. Throw scissors at him. Pam is the only one that clocks this as disturbing. Yes. We had two fan questions that I loved. The first is from Sessia Z in London, Ontario, Canada, who said, when Michael says that the box is from Sobre to Sobre us, Michael says the us is if he's referring to everyone in the office, but in reality, the us probably means United States. I think that's the funniest thing ever. I loved that. It didn't occur to me until I read this letter. Right. That's what he was doing. Our other bit of mail came from Haley H in Beaumont, Alberta, Canada, and also many others.
这意味着，我猜，把房间另一头的剪刀扔给他。把剪刀扔向他。帕姆是唯一一个认为这令人不安的人。是的。我们有两个我很喜欢的粉丝提问。第一个来自安大略省伦敦市的塞西亚·Z，他说，当迈克尔说这个箱子是来自 Sobre to Sobre us（从 Sobre 到 Sobre 我们）时，“us”的意思好像是指办公室里的所有人，但实际上，“us”可能指的是美国（United States）。我觉得这是史上最好笑的事。我很喜欢这个。直到我读到这封信我才想到这一点。对的。他当时是这个意思。我们的另一封邮件来自艾伯塔省博蒙特的海莉·H，还有许多其他人。
By the way, wrote in to say, how did you guys do the bit when Aaron throws the scissors to Michael? Are they fakie scissors? I hope so. Yes. They were fakie scissors. They were made by Phil Shea via the hand prop room. Randy Cordray confirmed that they were rubber, but they looked very real.
顺便说一句，来信写道，艾琳把剪刀扔给迈克尔的那场戏你们是怎么拍的？那是假剪刀吗？希望是吧。是的。那是假剪刀。它们是由菲尔·谢伊通过手部道具室制作的。兰迪·科德雷证实它们是橡胶的，但看起来非常真实。
I remember this about them. They did not open and close. They were permanently in the open position. They were rubber because they were rubber. Randy said that they added a special effects sound in post to make them sound like real scissors. So amazing. I kind of want to go to the hand prop room.
我对此有印象。它们不能开合。它们一直处于张开的状态。它们是橡胶的，因为它们就是橡胶做的。兰迪说，他们在后期制作中添加了特效声音，让它们听起来像真正的剪刀。太神奇了。我有点想去手部道具室看看了。
What are they making over there? Can we do a factory tour of the hand prop room? I would love nothing more. How does that work? I don't know. You call up and say, I need fakie scissors in the open position. Where do you do it?
他们在那里做什么？我们能去手部道具室进行一次工厂参观吗？我求之不得。那是怎么运作的？我不知道。你打电话过去说，我需要处于张开位置的假剪刀。你在哪里做这个？
How does this happen? I bet that's where Phil Shay had the teeny tiny real tennis racket made for my son's Halloween costume when he was a baby. We just have a lot of factory chores and I can't wait for each one. Hand-proper and we're coming for you. Well Michael is going to tear into this box with those rubber scissors. Yep. And there is a running joke in my family lady that I do it wrong when it comes to opening packages.
这怎么可能发生？我敢打赌，菲尔·谢伊就是在那儿为我儿子小时候的万圣节服装定制了那个微型真网球拍。我们有很多工厂参观活动，我已经迫不及待想要去每一个了。手部道具室，我们来啦。好吧，迈克尔要用那些橡胶剪刀撕开这个箱子了。是的。我的家人中流传着一个笑话，亲爱的，那就是我在拆快递时总是用错方法。
Do you open it like Michael? I just get it open. I get it open. So that's yes. So you know how like some packages come with like a little built-in Ziplocke thing? Yeah. And if you open it correctly, the Ziploc will work. Yeah. I never get it right. Okay. Like it's that's not going to happen. Or there will be a big thing that says peel here. I miss that every time. that's not going to happen. Or there will be a big thing that says, peel here. I miss that every time. That's not going to happen. So if something's really like just aster in the pantry, chances are I opened it. That's very funny.
你开箱像迈克尔那样吗？我直接弄开它。我把它弄开。所以是的。所以你知道有些包装带有那种小型的内置夹链条吗？对的。如果你打开方式正确，夹链就会起作用。我从来没弄对过。好吧。比如，那是行不通的。或者会有一个大大的标志写着“从这里撕开”。我每次都错过那个。如果是这样的话。所以如果有什么东西真的在储藏室里乱七八糟的，那很可能就是我打开的。太搞笑了。
I think you know how I open a box. I mean, probably meticulously along the little perforated line. Well, yeah, because number one, what if I need to reuse it? You know, what if I don't like what's inside and I have to return it? I'm gonna need that packaging. Oh, yeah. That's right.
我想你知道我是怎么开箱的。我的意思是，可能是一丝不苟地顺着那个小小的穿孔线。好吧，是的，因为第一，如果我需要重复使用它怎么办？你知道，如果我不喜欢里面的东西必须退货怎么办？我会需要那个包装的。哦，是的。没错。
Or what if I do like what's inside? I'm gonna wanna break that down and put it in the recycling. You know what I mean? I'll break it down. I mean, it's already broken down by the time I open it. Anyway, when I saw that scene,
或者如果我喜欢里面的东西怎么办？我会想要把它拆扁然后放进回收箱。你知道我的意思吗？我会把它拆扁。我的意思是，等我打开它的时候它就已经被拆扁了。总之，当我看到那一幕时，
I was like, Josh, is that me? And he was like, yeah. That's amazing. Yeah. Well, when I saw that scene, I was like, Josh, is that me? And he was like, uh, yeah. That's amazing. Yeah. Well, Michael's gonna have a great talking head now where he explains that Dunderclund was acquired by an electronics company that saw Bray, stepped in and saved their butts at the 11th hour.
我就想：乔希，那是我吗？他就会说：是的。太惊人了。是的。好吧，当我看到那一幕时，我就想：乔希，那是我吗？他就会说：呃，是的。太惊人了。是的。好吧，迈克尔现在要发表一段精彩的单人独白，解释邓德米夫林被一家名为 Sobre 的电子公司收购了，该公司挺身而出，在最后关头拯救了他们。
I wanna point out that during this talking head at 29 seconds, Chris Workman, who was our first assistant camera operator, is the person who is putting up the saber sign underneath the Dunder Mifflin sign in the lobby. That's Chris. Oh, I love that. Well, there was a candy bag talking head alternate.
我想指出的是，在 29 秒的这段单人独白中，我们的第一助理摄像师克里斯·沃克曼，正是那个在大厅邓德米夫林招牌下方挂上 Saber 招牌的人。那是克里斯。哦，我真喜欢这个。好吧，还有一个关于糖果袋的备选单人独白。
Oh. And it was a must shoot. So we shot this, but it wasn't used. And I just loved it so much. Here was the alt talking head for Michael. Dundermiflin was recently bought out by an electronics company named Sobre. Great things come from the south, like Chilly and Wyoming. Well, now you can add another distinguished name to that list. Michael, rodeo, cowboy, Garth Brooks, Scott. Here is Wyoming.
哦。这是一场必拍的戏。所以我们拍了，但没用上。我太喜欢它了。以下是迈克尔的备选单人独白。邓德米夫林最近被一家名为 Sobre 的电子公司收购了。伟大的事物都来自南方，比如奇利和怀俄明州。好吧，现在你可以在这个名单上加上另一个杰出的名字了。迈克尔，牛仔竞技，牛仔加思·布鲁克斯，斯科特。这就是怀俄明州。
I don't know. He thinks it's the South, it's not the South. But that's just so funny to me that he's like, great things come from the South. Like me and a rodeo and a cowboy and... Garth Brooks. Garth Brooks, you're shouting things out. Chili, it's Wyoming.
我不知道。他以为那是南方，其实并不是南方。但我觉得这太好笑了，他居然说：伟大的事物都来自南方。就像我和牛仔竞技、牛仔……加思·布鲁克斯。加思·布鲁克斯，你就在那儿大喊大叫。奇利，那是怀俄明州。
At 42 seconds, you see Michael taking everything out of the box. There is the saber graphics on each product that was, of course, created by our graphics designer, Henry Sain. Phil Shea once again used the hand prop room to fabricate the individual product boxes that everything came in. I'm going to stock this place. I'm going to the hand proper. I know. I know. You know what, Ange? I recently had to do props for my son's fourth grade play. Jenna, you were so excited about it. You left me several messages. You were giddy because it was a play that was set during the gold rush. It was so cool. The class writes the play themselves based on a topic they're learning in class. They were learning about hydraulic mining that was set during the gold rush. It was so cool. The class writes the play themselves
在 42 秒时，你看到迈克尔把箱子里的所有东西都拿出来。每个产品上都有 Saber 的图形，这当然是由我们的平面设计师亨利·塞恩设计的。菲尔·谢伊再次利用手部道具室制作了装有所有物品的独立产品盒。我要去这个地方视察。我要去手部道具室。我知道。我知道。你知道吗，安吉？我最近不得不为我儿子的四年级戏剧制作道具。詹娜，你对此太兴奋了。你给我留了好几条语音。你激动得不得了，因为这是一部以淘金热为背景的戏剧。太酷了。全班同学根据他们在课堂上学到的主题自己写剧本。他们当时正在学习淘金热期间的水力采矿。太酷了。全班同学自己写剧本
based on a topic they're learning in class. They were learning about hydraulic mining and government regulations during the gold rush. So that's what they wrote their play about. And I was on the props team and they needed an old-timey camera and an old-timey typewriter and an old-timey cash register.
根据他们在课堂上学到的主题。他们当时在学习淘金热时期的水力采矿和政府法规。所以这就是他们剧本的内容。我是道具组的，他们需要一台老式相机、一台老式打字机和一台老式收银机。
Guess who I called? Phil Shea. Phil Shea! Phil was like, I know where to send you. You need to go to this place called History for Higher. And they have all old-timey stuff. Like an old-timey telephone and old-timey box of cereal, whatever you need in there.
你猜我给谁打了电话？菲尔·谢伊！菲尔·谢伊！菲尔说：我知道该把你送到哪儿去。你需要去一个叫 History for Higher（历史租赁）的地方。他们有所有老式的东西。比如老式电话、老式麦片盒，你在里面需要什么都有。
And you kind of rent it like a library, like how you used to check out a book. Yes. So I go into this place. It's a huge warehouse. It's actually very close to where we shot our show over on Sategory. I was like, oh my god, this is the greatest museum.
你可以像去图书馆借书一样去租它，就像你以前借书一样。是的。所以我走进了那个地方。这是一个巨大的仓库。它实际上离我们拍戏的地方很近，就在 Sategory 那边。我当时想：哦，天哪，这是最棒的博物馆。
I spent like a half hour there just like walking around. It was amazing. Am I going to go into like props? Maybe. Maybe. I don't know. Does Phil need an assistant and in turn something? Oh my gosh.
我在那儿花了大约半小时四处闲逛。太神奇了。我会进入道具行业吗？也许吧。也许吧。我不知道。菲尔需要一个助理或者实习生什么的吗？哦，天哪。
A pro de chez. You know what I would love? I would love to show up to a set and you walk out with a tray of different types of like mallard ducks for me to use in my scene. I'm like Jenna, I'm working with Phil today. I'm working with Phil. We've got a lot of boxes.
首席道具师。你知道我想要什么吗？我希望能出现在一个片场，然后你端着一盘各种类型的绿头鸭走出来，让我用在我的场景里。我会说：詹娜，我今天跟菲尔一起工作。我在跟菲尔工作。我们有很多箱子。
And I'm gonna use a silver tray because that's what. That's how you do it. Yeah. How filled taught me? Well, this box contains a new printer for accounting, a fax machine for sales, and the thing Michael is most excited about a scanner. Yes. He immediately starts scanning weird things like a child would. You know, Jenna, I just got so tickled when I saw Michael playing with the scanner
我要用一个银盘子，因为那是。你是怎么做的。菲尔是怎么教我的？好吧，这个箱子里有一个用于会计的新打印机，一个用于销售的传真机，以及迈克尔最兴奋的东西——扫描仪。是的。他马上开始像个小孩子一样扫描奇怪的东西。你知道吗，詹娜，当我看到迈克尔玩扫描仪时，我真是觉得太逗了，
because in my grandmother's early 90s, that's what she wanted for Christmas one year. And we got her a scanner and she was so delighted by it. She had all of these like newspaper clippings and anything that any of her grandkids ever accomplished or were written up about, she had saved them all. And she just started scanning them. She was just archiving. She was archiving in her 90s. Bless her heart. I know. I know. Well Michael is scanning his little hamster toy. Yeah. Not the same. Not the same. And that's when Aaron's like, yeah, this box was for a Gabe.
因为在我奶奶 90 年代初的时候，那是她有一年圣诞节想要的礼物。我们给她买了一个扫描仪，她高兴坏了。她把所有这些剪报，以及她的孙子孙女们取得的任何成就或被报道过的事情都收集了起来，她把它们全都存了起来。她开始扫描它们。她在 90 多岁的时候还在做档案归档。愿上帝保佑她。我知道。我知道。好吧，迈克尔在扫描他的小仓鼠玩具。是的。不一样。不一样。就在那时，艾琳说：等等，这个箱子是给盖布的。
It said set aside for Gabe. Yeah, so now they have to get all of the things and they have to put it all back into the box and seal it up. I loved this scene. I love this scene so much. You and I were recently asked an interview what we are loving about this rewatch. And I am loving these big ensemble scenes where we all have to do one ridiculous task together. Oh my gosh. Pam and Oscar are trying to put the stuff in the box with everybody weighing in. Amazing.
上面写着留给盖布。是的，所以现在他们必须把所有的东西都拿出来，再把它们全部放回箱子里并封好。我很喜欢这个场景。我太喜欢这个场景了。你和我最近在一次采访中被问到我们最喜欢这次重温的什么。我喜欢这些大型群戏场景，我们必须一起完成一项荒谬的任务。哦，天哪。帕姆和奥斯卡正试图把东西放进箱子里，大家都在七嘴八舌地发表意见。太惊人了。
Amazing. By the way, I want to say at two minutes, 14 seconds in the background on the wall. The watercolor is back. Finally! Finally, nine episodes later. Wow, it's back and it will be there. Yay, hope in a frame on the wall, on the wall.
太惊人了。顺便说一句，我想说在 2 分 14 秒时，背景墙上。那幅水彩画又回来了。终于！终于，九集之后。哇，它回来了，而且它会一直呆在那里。耶，裱在框里的希望挂在墙上，挂在墙上。
So now we have the opening credits of this show and I don't know if you notice, but we've got to Mr. Ed Helms in there now. Yes. At his desk, we get a quick shot of him. Ryan is no longer holding up his bag of basketball stuff. Instead, we've got Ed Helms at the top. His movie was a very, very big success.
现在我们看到了节目的片头，我不知道你们有没有注意到，现在里面有埃德·赫尔姆斯先生了。是的。在他的办公桌旁，我们看到了他的一闪而过的镜头。瑞安不再举着他的篮球装备包了。相反，我们在最上面看到了埃德·赫尔姆斯。他的电影非常、非常成功。
Yes. He moved right into those opening credits. He sure did. Well, everyone is very excited. They're waiting for Gabe's arrival. And Pam's like, Michael, what do you want us to do? And he's like, do I have to explain everything? And she's like, yes, because usually we're not
是的。他直接进入了片头字幕。他确实做到了。好吧，大家都非常兴奋。他们在等待盖布的到来。帕姆说：迈克尔，你想让我们做什么？他却说：难道所有事都要我解释吗？她就说：是的，因为通常我们都不在
on the same page. And then they just all start applauding. And she's like, I'm saying she, it was me. I know. Pam is like, I guess this is what we're doing. Well, this is what we're doing now. Okay. Well, guys, new character alert,
同一个频道上。然后他们就都开始鼓掌。她说：我说的是她，其实是我。我知道。帕姆好像在说：我想我们现在就是在做这个。好吧，这就是我们现在在做的事情。好吧，伙计们，新角色预警，
Zach Woods played gay, Bluice. Zach Woods was born in Trenton, New Jersey and is a graduate of NYU. This is your bio voice. It is. It will now read a bio. I have a new bio voice. No, okay.
扎克·伍兹饰演盖布·刘易斯。扎克·伍兹出生于新泽西州特伦顿，毕业于纽约大学。这是你的个人简介播音腔。是的。现在它将朗读一份个人简介。我换了一个新的个人简介播音腔。不，好吧。
At age 16, he began performing improv at upright citizens brigade. Doesn't it sound like you could be watching like a montage of his life over this narration? Sort of. Okay. Close your eyes, visualize. Okay, I'm gonna close my eyes. He has even taught improv at UCB, Columbia, and Duke universities as well as at Lincoln Center.
在 16 岁时，他开始在“垂直公民剧团”（UCB）表演即兴喜剧。听起来是不是像你在听他的生平蒙太奇伴随着这段旁白？有点像。好吧，闭上眼睛，想象一下。好吧，我要闭上眼睛。他甚至曾在 UCB、哥伦比亚大学和杜克大学以及林肯中心教授过即兴表演。
In addition to his role on the office, Zach is well known for his roles on such shows as Veepe, the Good Wife and Silicon Valley, fan question from Kyle T. in Houston, Texas. Do y'all have a favorite story about working with Zach Woods? Kyle, every story about working with Zach Woods is my favorite. He is one of my favorite people, professionally, personally.
除了在《办公室》中的角色外，扎克还因在《副总统》、《傲骨贤妻》和《硅谷》等剧集中的角色而闻名，这是来自得克萨斯州休斯敦的凯尔·T 的粉丝提问。你们有没有关于和扎克·伍兹合作的最喜欢的的故事？凯尔，关于和扎克·伍兹合作的每一个故事都是我最喜欢的。无论是职业上还是个人私下，他都是我最喜欢的人之一。
He is a gem of a human being. Kyle, I'm going to tell you right now. He is straight up good people. He is good people. And he's so flipping funny, so funny, so funny. And I love improv. You know, that's my background. And I would lose myself in a scene because I would watch him go
他是一个绝佳的人类。凯尔，我现在就告诉你。他绝对是个好人。他是个好人。而且他太搞笑、太搞笑、太搞笑了。我喜欢即兴表演。你知道的，那是我的背景。我会全身心地投入到一个场景中，因为我会看着他在合适的时刻即兴发挥
off script at the right moment. It was never selfish. It was like exactly if we needed something, he was just perfection. I was like, beyond impressed with him. He has a command of language in improv that is like, otherworldly. There are some great bloopers of him just talking. And he doesn't stop talking, but he's not even saying jokes. He's just like, it's so funny. And people are dying. We could get through scenes.
脱离剧本。这从来不是出于私心。这就像如果我们正好需要什么，他就会做到完美。我就想：对他佩服得五体投地。他在即兴表演中对语言的掌控力简直是超乎寻常的。有一些他一直在说话的精彩NG花絮。而且他滔滔不绝，但甚至都不是在讲笑话。他只是——太搞笑了。大家都在笑死。我们都无法拍完场景。
Well, he never went for the joke. That's what I mean, that he was patient and not selfish. He was never about the joke. Anyway, we could go on and on. He was wonderful. Kyle, we loved him. We loved him. You know, there's a lot in the shooting draft that didn't make it in the script and there is a scene that starts an accounting runner or right here that I wanted to share with you guys. Oh, because it's gonna reveal a little bit of Oscar's backstory.
好吧，他从来不刻意去抖包袱。这就是我的意思，他很有耐心，而且没有私心。他从不为了搞笑而搞笑。总之，我们可以说个没完。他太棒了。凯尔，我们太爱他了。我们太爱他了。你知道，拍摄剧本里有很多内容没有进入正片，这里有一个以会计室为起点的支线剧情，我想和大家分享。哦，因为这会透露一点奥斯卡的背景故事。
Really? Yes. Okay. Here's a hint. It involves Vance refrigeration. What? I know, right? Gotcha, guess. And now, in the script, Gabe is on his way up, right? Yep. And in accounting, Angela quickly swipes a big stack from Kevin's desk into the trash. Oh. Kevin says, hey, what are you doing?
真的吗？是的。好吧。给个提示。它涉及万斯制冷公司。什么？我知道，对吧？猜中了吧。现在，在剧本中，盖布正在上楼，对吧？是的。而在会计室里，安吉拉迅速把凯文桌子上的一大叠东西扫进了垃圾桶。哦。凯文说：嘿，你在干什么？
Angela says, this is accounting. It's not your home, your car, or your stomach. Hmm. Kevin says, joke's on you because that was work stuff in there. Angela says, it was fake work. I gave all the real work to Oscar today. To which Kevin goes, hey, an Oscar goes again. Lady, I remember reading this at the table read,
安吉拉说：这是会计室。这里不是你的家、你的车，也不是你的胃。嗯。凯文说：那你就失算了，因为里面有工作的文件。安吉拉说：那是假工作。我今天把所有真工作都给奥斯卡了。凯文接着说：嘿，奥斯卡又来了。亲爱的，我记得在台词围读时听到这个，
and it was so funny this idea that Angela gives Kevin fakey work. Yes. Well, this runner continues throughout the episode. There's two more beats to it. I'll share it when it happens. Oh my gosh, I totally remember that. Well, listen, once Gabe does come into the office, he is presented with a platter of Scranton hot dogs. My favorite part of this beat was watching rain as Dwight try to figure out where to set the hot dogs down. Mm-hmm. And there was no place to set them down. We got a fan question from Sophia and Maryland about that.
安吉拉给凯文布置假工作的这个想法实在是太搞笑了。是的。好吧，这个支线剧情贯穿了整集。后面还有两个节点。等它发生时我会分享的。哦，天哪，我完全记起来了。好吧，听着，一旦盖布走进办公室，就会端上一盘斯克兰顿热狗。我最喜欢这一段的是看着雷恩饰演的德怀特试图找出把热狗放在哪里。嗯哼。结果根本没有地方放下。我们收到了来自马里兰州的索菲亚关于这事的粉丝提问。
Sophia wanted to know when Dwight awkwardly places the tray of hot dogs on the floor in front of Gabe was this scripted or improvised. Sophia, that was scripted. You were watching just Rain Wilson do some brilliant execution of a scripted moment. I became curious about this pride that Dwight had over the fact that these were scranton hot dogs. I wondered, is there something that I don't know about? Yeah, there are Scranton dogs. Scranton dog? Yeah, and hot dogs?
索菲亚想知道，当德怀特尴尬地把一盘热狗放在盖布面前的地上时，这是剧本里写好的还是即兴发挥的。索菲亚，那是剧本写好的。你看到的是雷恩·威尔逊对一个剧本桥段的精彩演绎。我对德怀特为这些是斯克兰顿热狗而感到骄傲这一点产生了好奇。我在想，难道有什么是我不知道的吗？是的，有斯克兰顿热狗。斯克兰顿热狗？是的，还有热狗？
Well, according to Pennsylvania eats, they have an article called the Pennsylvania hot dog bucket list. You can just travel through Pennsylvania eating hot dogs. And here's what it said. For an old school hot dog experience in Scranton, look no further than Coney Island lunch, where it's all about Texas winters,
好吧，根据“宾州美食网”的报道，他们有一篇名为《宾夕法尼亚热狗愿望清单》的文章。你可以一路游历宾夕法尼亚并品尝热狗。文章是这样说的。如果你想在斯克兰顿体验老派热狗，那就不容错过“科尼岛午餐”（Coney Island Lunch），那里的一切都关乎得克萨斯维纳香肠（Texas wieners），
which are a bit different than your standard hot dog. Using a 93 year old recipe, Coney Island lunch makes its hot dogs with a burks-all beef weiner on a national bakery roll topped with doosledorf mustard fresh diced onions and its famous chili sauce which is also available for sale by the pint or quart. Though not quite traditional you can also top yours with cheddar cheese sauce sweet relish and sour crout. Beloved the region, this lunch counters Texas Weiner was named third best in the USA, wow, by Fox News,
这与你的标准热狗略有不同。科尼岛午餐采用拥有 93 年历史的配方，其热狗采用伯克斯全牛肉维纳香肠，配上国家面包店的面包，浇上杜塞尔多夫芥末、新鲜切碎的洋葱以及他们著名的辣椒酱，辣椒酱还按品脱或夸脱出售。虽然不太传统，但你也可以在上面浇上切达干酪酱、甜酸菜碎和酸菜。这款深受该地区喜爱的午餐柜台的得克萨斯维纳香肠被福克斯新闻评为全美第三名，哇，
and it was also ranked on the Daily Meals list of the 35 best hot dogs in America. So I guess Scranton is making the dogs. So this was true, true. As everyone's applauding for Gabe, Gabe applauds right back and says, and to you. Amazing, amazing moment. And Michael says, you know, we're so excited to meet you. We've even prepared a song for you. Yes. To which Gabe says, oh, I'm going to record it and put it on the Saber website. And immediately Michael looks at everyone and goes Saber.
它还在《每日膳食》评选的美国 35 家最佳热狗榜单上名列前茅。所以我想斯克兰顿确实在做热狗。所以这是真的，真的。当大家为盖布鼓掌时，盖布也回以掌声并说：也送给你们。太惊艳、太惊艳的时刻了。迈克尔说：你知道的，我们非常高兴能见到你。我们甚至为你准备了一首歌。是的。对此盖布说：哦，我要把它录下来放到 Saber 网站上。迈克尔立刻看着大家说：Saber。
Saber and everyone's like, oh, Saber. Oh, Saber. Saber. Well, it's not gonna be enough time for Andy and Aaron to adjust their song that they've planned. Mm-hmm. It is amazing, this song. It is a song parody to the tune of party in the USA
Saber，大家齐声说：哦，Saber。哦，Saber。Saber。好吧，安迪和艾琳根本没有时间调整他们计划好的歌曲。嗯哼。这首歌太惊艳了。这是一首改编自麦莉·赛勒斯的歌曲《Party in the USA》（美国派对）的歌曲。我觉得我们应该听一听。但第一次，这是伟大的。你看到了电力城标志。这将是美好的一天。但你千万别错过答案，呼吸。那是 Saber。
by Miley Cyrus. I thought we should listen to it. But the first time, it's the great And you see the electric city sign This is gonna be a good day But don't you miss an answer, breathe It's a breathe Saber It's saber Don't you miss an answer, breathe So yeah, yeah, yeah
那是 Saber。你千万别错过答案，呼吸。所以，耶，耶，耶。
Don't you miss an answer, breathe So yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah Don't you miss an answer, the book is a part of Saber. It's a part of Saber. Oh my God, it makes me laugh so hard. They're really good too. I know they are. We had a fan question from Rachel S. In Benton, Arkansas,
你千万别错过答案，呼吸。所以，耶，耶，耶，耶。你千万别错过答案，这本书是 Saber 的一部分。它是 Saber 的一部分。哦，天哪，这把我笑得太惨了。他们唱得也真好。我知道他们唱得好。我们收到了来自阿肯色州本顿市的Rachel S.的粉丝提问，
who wrote the Saber song to the tune party in the USA. Rachel, it was scripted by our writers Warren Lieberstein and Hallstead Sullivan. Remember those are the guys who wrote Koi Pond. Now, Jen Solata shared that they also had to write lyrics to two other songs because they didn't know what song was eventually going to get cleared. So I guess they wrote lyrics to I got a feeling my black eyed peas and Serfen in the USA by the beach boys, but they did eventually get the rights to party in the USA. It's something called song parody rights and it cost $23,000.
谁把 Saber 的歌改编成了《Party in the USA》的曲调？Rachel，这是我们的编剧沃伦·利伯斯坦和霍尔斯特德·沙利文写进剧本的。记住，就是他们写了《锦鲤池》那一集。现在，珍·萨洛塔分享说，他们还得另外两首歌写歌词，因为他们不知道最终会通过哪首歌的版权。所以我想他们为黑眼豆豆的《I got a feeling》和海滩男孩的《Surfin' USA》写了歌词，但他们最终还是获得了《Party in the USA》的版权。这叫做歌曲改编版权，花费了 23,000 美元。
Well, I texted Warren about this and I was like, how did you guys get assigned to writing this? And he said, Halstead and I both sang Acapella in college and we were a little nerdy about it. This was before pitch perfect made Acapella nerdy cool. So the writers kind of knew us as that. We always jumped at the chance to write lyrics for anything. It was just fun for us. Lady, both your ex-husband and your current husband sang a cappella in college. No. There is a thread to follow there.
好吧，我为此给沃伦发了短信，问：你们是怎么被指派写这个的？他说：霍尔斯特德和我上大学时都唱过阿卡贝拉（无伴奏合唱），我们对此有点书呆子气。这在《完美音调》让阿卡贝拉变得书呆子式酷炫之前。所以编剧们基本上把我们当成那样的人。我们总是抓住机会为任何事情写歌词。这对我们来说只是好玩。亲爱的，你的前夫和现夫上大学时都在唱阿卡贝拉。不。这里面有某种内在联系。
I know, although when I was in college, I didn't know anyone that did a cappella. A ca what? A ca what? Well, lady, thanks to our writer's assistant, Rob Burnett, I was able to get a hold of the Serfen in the USA version of the Sobre song. And Cassie had her friend, Yaki Margulies, who is an actor musician and big beach boys fan,
我知道，虽然我上大学时，我不认识任何玩阿卡贝拉的人。阿卡什么？阿卡什么？好吧，亲爱的，多亏了我们的编剧助理罗布·伯内特，我才得以弄到 Saber 之歌的《Surfin' USA》版本。卡西请她的朋友亚基·马古利斯（Yaki Margulies）来录制，他是一位演员兼音乐家，也是海滩男孩的超级粉丝，
recorded for us. Here it is. From Dallas, see you away Thanks for making the long trip To Dundra Miffin B.A. Have a coffee and don't know Take off your coat and stay Over there that's fitness She's working for Sabre And back there in the end
为我们录制了这首歌。以下是录音。来自达拉斯，见到你很高兴。感谢你长途跋涉来到邓德米夫林。喝杯咖啡，别客气。脱下外套留下来。那边那是菲特尼斯，她在为 Saber 工作。而在最后面，
Dundra Miff, Kelly and Ryan play. Kevin Oscar and Bam Choo, and the numbers all day. And everyone on the set, team, and dr. Smith, prepare anything to pay. Are happy to be working, working for Sabre. Happy to be working, working for Sabre. Happy to be working, working for Sabre. Happy to be working, working for Sabre. Happy to be working. I mean, that is an amazing Brian Wilson impression.
邓德米夫林里，凯莉和瑞安在玩。凯文、奥斯卡和帕姆在欢呼，数字数了一整天。片场、团队和邓德米夫林的每个人，准备好支付任何代价。都很高兴能工作，为 Saber 工作。很高兴能工作，为 Saber 工作。很高兴能工作，为 Saber 工作。很高兴能工作，为 Saber 工作。很高兴能工作。我的意思是，那是一个惊人的布莱恩·威尔逊模仿秀。
It's so good. So it's so taking good. And Warren and Hallstead had to write all those lyrics for that. I know. And talk about small world. I know, Yaki. I know. So he officiates bar and bot mitzvahs and he officiated a bot mitzvah that you were
太像了。真的太像了。沃伦和霍尔斯特德为此写了所有的歌词。我知道。真是个小世界。我知道，亚基。我知道。他主持犹太成人礼（Bar and Bat Mitzvah），他最近在奥海主持了一场你出席的犹太成人礼。就在三个星期前。太疯狂了。他太棒了。亚基，谢谢你。好吧，吉姆简直是个可爱的准爸爸。他查好了地图路线。
at in ohai like very recently. Three weeks ago. That's crazy. He is wonderful. That was so great. Yaki, thank you. Well Jim is being just adorable new dad. He's map quested directions. Even though it's just a few minutes away to their appointment to look at a daycare, Pam and Jim are gonna tour daycares. Can I say something? What? In this scene. Yes, Jim is being adorable, but at five minutes and nine seconds, that fuzzy, eyes have closed, frizzy-haired photo of Pam is very clearly on Jim's desk. What is that? What is that? I don't know. It is so bizarre to me that this is a photo that has made its way into a frame ever
尽管离他们去看托儿所的预约地点只有几分钟车程，但帕姆和吉姆还是要去参观托儿所。我能说件事吗？什么？在这个场景里。是的，吉姆是很可爱，但是在 5 分钟 9 秒时，吉姆桌上赫然摆着那张帕姆蓬头垢面、双眼紧闭、头发卷曲的照片。那是什么？那是什么？我不知道。这张照片居然能被放进相框里，而且还如此显眼地摆在吉姆的桌子上，这让我觉得太诡异了。也许那就是他爱上的年轻姑娘。那一头卷发。她眼睛都睁不全。
and is so prominently on Jim's desk. Maybe that's the young gal he fell in love with. That frizzy hair. She can't open her eyes all the way. No, I know. She's constantly mid-blink. My sister Billy rarely has her eyes open in any photo. I don't know. I'll let it go, but it's there. Pam and Jim have a talking head where they
不，我知道。她一直在中途眨眼。我姐姐比利在任何照片里都很少睁开眼睛。我不知道。我放过它吧，但它确实在那儿。帕姆和吉姆有一段单人独白，他们
explain that they have found a very highly rated local daycare. It's very hard to get into. So they have to go in for an interview. Yeah. And I think Jim has his first dad pun, where he says, if not, there's always the army, the infantry. He's so ready to be a dad. Dad pun! Way to go. Well, there was an alt-jim-pam talking head that was in the shooting draft.
解释说他们找到了一家当地评价很高的托儿所。很难进去。所以他们必须去面试。是的。而且我想吉姆有了他的第一个爸爸冷笑话，他说：如果不去，还有军队、步兵可以选。他已经完全准备好当爸爸了。爸爸冷笑话！干得好。好吧，拍摄剧本里有一段吉姆和帕姆的备选单人独白。
It was a must-shoot. I have to read it to you. It made me laugh. Okay. Pam says, we found a great local daycare, but it's really hard to get into. Jim says, ideally, we would have called the moment we conceived. Pam says, but usually you fall right asleep. Whoa! Okay, some TMI there. Yeah. About Jim and Pam. I know. That was a must shoot. So you shot that. It exists somewhere. Wow. That is so much more than we need to know about their private life, I think. I have noticed in
这是一场必拍的戏。我得读给你们听。把我逗笑了。好吧。帕姆说：我们找到了当地一家很棒的托儿所，但真的很难进去。吉姆说：理想情况下，我们应该在一怀上就打电话。帕姆说：但通常你马上就睡着了。哇！好吧，里面有一些过度分享的私密信息。关于吉姆和帕姆的。我知道。那是必拍戏。所以你们拍了。它存在于某个地方。哇。我觉得这比我们想知道的关于他们私生活的要多得多。我注意到在
the shooting draft whenever we get to the Alts that sometimes they do peel back a layer to Jim and Pam and they always back away from it. They always end up not picking it. Well, now we're going to go into the conference room and Gabe is going to play an introduction video. It is a video about the new company that has acquired them, Saber, and it is starring Christian Slater as Christian Slater. I know. Michael has never been more impressed. Oh, he, I mean, now he's so excited about this company. Oh yeah, I thought we needed to hear it. So you've just been bought by Saber. Probably a lot of questions. Hi, I'm Christian Slater. What's it like to work for Saber? Let's find out together. Working at Saber means taking on the challenge of the road that rises to meet you.
拍摄剧本中，每当我们看到备选内容时，有时他们确实会揭开吉姆和帕姆生活的一层外衣，但他们总是又退缩了。他们总是以不采用告终。好吧，现在我们要进入会议室，盖布要播放一段介绍视频。这是一个关于收购他们的公司 Saber 的视频，由克里斯蒂安·斯莱特饰演克里斯蒂安·斯莱特。我知道。迈克尔从来没有这么佩服过谁。哦，他，我的意思是，现在他对这家公司兴奋极了。哦，是的，我觉得我们需要听听看。所以你们刚刚被 Saber 收购了。可能有很多问题。嗨，我是克里斯蒂安·斯莱特。为 Saber 工作是什么感觉？让我们一起去发现。在 Saber 工作意味着接受迎接扑面而来的道路的挑战。
Saber, respecting the past, but opening the window to the future. Have you overtasted a rainbow? Good Saber, you will. You'll find it easy to embrace the saber spirit. Welcome. We're very excited to go on this journey with you. Okay. Can I say something?
Saber，尊重过去，但为未来打开一扇窗。你品尝过彩虹的味道吗？好的 Saber，你会的。你会发现拥抱 Saber 精神是多么容易。欢迎。我们非常高兴能与你们一同踏上这段旅程。好的。我能说句话吗？
This video opens with the line, so you've just been bought by Saber. How many companies have they bought? That's what I want to know. Like is this something they made just for this acquisition or is this like a thing they have? No, they've bought so many companies and had odd transitions they had to make the video. That's my theory. Well, we got a lot of mail, a fan mail flurry asking, how did we get Christian Slater to star
这个视频的开场白是：所以你们刚刚被 Saber 收购了。他们到底收购了多少公司？这是我想知道的。就像这是他们专为这次收购制作的东西，还是他们本来就有的东西？不，他们收购了太多公司，经历了各种奇怪的过渡，所以他们必须制作这个视频。这就是我的理论。好吧，我们收到了大量粉丝邮件，
in this crazy video? Well I found an interview that Christian Slater did for Entertainment Weekly about his experience on our show. Here's what he had to say. John Krasinski directed the episode and he and I sort of know each other from different types of events. And he's a really nice dude. He called my agent and was wondering if I'd be available
询问我们是怎么请到克里斯蒂安·斯莱特来主演这个疯狂视频的？好吧，我找到了克里斯蒂安·斯莱特为《娱乐周刊》做的一段采访，讲述了他在我们剧中的经历。他是这样说的。约翰·卡拉辛斯基导演了这一集，他和我在不同类型的活动中算是认识。他是个非常好的家伙。他给我的经纪人打电话，想知道我是否有空
to do this fantastic PSA on Saber, the company that bought Dunder Mifflin. And somehow it worked out with the schedule, it was kind of incredible. Wow, so John did it. John made it happen. Way to go. Well, Johnson in an audio clip about
来拍这个关于 Saber 的精彩公益广告，Saber 就是收购了邓德米夫林的那个公司。不知怎么的，档期居然排开了，真是不可思议。哇，所以是约翰促成的。约翰促成了这件事。干得漂亮。好吧，约翰发来了一段音频，讲述了
what it was like to work with Christian Slater, here it is. One of the greatest memories for me in directing this episode was directing that industrial video for Saber. I mean, just being on set with Kristen Slater was a pretty big highlight of my career. Not only was he one of my favorite actors growing up, but he was the nicest, nicest human being. And with such a big fan of the show and you could tell,
和克里斯蒂安·斯莱特合作是什么感觉，音频在这里。我导演这一集时最伟大的回忆之一，就是导演了那段关于 Saber 的工业宣传视频。我的意思是，能和克里斯蒂安·斯莱特一起在片场，可以说是我的职业生涯中的一个重大亮点。他不仅是我成长过程中最喜欢的演员之一，而且人极其好、极其善良。而且他是该剧的超级粉丝，你看得出来，
he actually just exuded this excitement to be on set, totally understood the joke and knew what he was doing and it was just so much fun. Well, Randy Cordray also shared with us that Christian Slater was a dream to work with, a total professional, cordial, friendly, and engaging with everyone on set. And Randy said, when we wrapped his work, I witnessed Christian giving up his seat in a courtesy shuttle van so that the entire hair and makeup team
他确实流露出能来到片场的兴奋之感，完全理解这个笑话，知道自己在做什么，真的超级有趣。好吧，兰迪·科德雷也跟我们分享说，和克里斯蒂安·斯莱特合作简直是梦想成真，绝对的专业人士，热情、友善，与片场每个人都相处融洽。兰迪说，当他的戏份杀青时，我亲眼看到克里斯蒂安把礼宾面包车上的座位让出来，好让整个发型和化妆团队
could travel together. Well, that's a Steve Carell move right there. I know, so classy. Mm-hmm. We did not get to meet Christian Slater. We didn't get to work with him, we were so bummed. We were majorly bummed. Because everyone was talking about what a nice guy he was.
能一起出行。好吧，这绝对是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔式的举动。我知道，太有绅士风度了。嗯哼。我们没有见到克里斯蒂安·斯莱特。我们没有和他一起工作，我们太失望了。我们超级沮丧。因为大家都说他是个多么好的人。
Well, we got a fan question from Natasha in Wales. Where was the Christian Slater sequence shot? Was it close by? I got a location breakdown from Randy Cordray. Do it. The interior shots, including the cafeteria, which by the way I asked Randy, was that the IKEA cafeteria?
好吧，我们收到了来自威尔士娜塔莎的粉丝提问。克里斯蒂安·斯莱特的那些镜头是在哪里拍摄的？离得近吗？我拿到了兰迪·科德雷提供的拍摄地明细。快说。室内镜头，包括自助餐厅，顺便说一句，我问过兰迪，那是宜家餐厅吗？
It really looks like my IKEA cafeteria. It really does. We go to the same one. I was like, where are the meatballs? That looks likeia cafeteria. It really looks like my IKEA cafeteria. It really does. We go to the same one. I was like, where are the meatballs that looks like a cafeteria? He said no. They were filmed at the Lakeview Corporate Center in West Lake Village, California. Randy said that they were mostly unoccupied at the time. So we were able to dress them to look like whatever we needed. We made that cafeteria. The exterior shots were shot at the backster building. Randy complemented our locations manager Kyle Alexander
它看起来真的很像我的宜家餐厅。确实很像。我们去的是同一家。我当时就想：肉丸在哪里？那看起来像宜家餐厅。它看起来真的很像我的宜家餐厅。确实很像。我们去的是同一家。我当时就想：肉丸在哪里？那看起来像宜家餐厅。他说不是。它们是在加利福尼亚州西湖村的湖景企业中心拍摄的。兰迪说当时那里基本是空置的。所以我们可以根据需要把它布置成任何样子。我们打造了那个自助餐厅。室外镜头是在巴克斯特大楼拍摄的。兰迪称赞了我们的外景经理凯尔·亚历山大。
because he was able to find these two spots right next to one another. It made it really easy to shoot those sequences in one day. And John shared that when they got to the location, that exterior location, there was a pond in front of the building, and it had a bunch of ducks in it, like 30 ducks, and John was super excited. He absolutely loved this detail, so he put Christian Slaters opening shot right in front of the pond with the ducks,
因为他能够找到这两个紧挨着彼此的地点。这使得在一天内拍摄那些镜头变得非常容易。约翰分享说，当他们到达那个外景地，也就是建筑前方有一个池塘，里面有一群鸭子，大概有30只，约翰超级兴奋。他非常喜欢这个细节，所以他把克里斯蒂安·史莱特的开场镜头直接放在了养着鸭子的池塘前面，
but right before they were about to shoot, one of the location guys got into the pond because they were trying to get the ducks to come just a little bit closer to camera. Yes, but guess what? All the ducks flew away. They were like, get out of our pond, Mr. John was so bummed. And then our writer, Jen Salada, shared that Greg Daniels pitched that line,
但在他们准备拍摄之前，其中一个制景人员走进了池塘，因为他们想引诱鸭子离镜头更近一点。是的，但你猜怎么着？所有的鸭子都飞走了。它们好像在说，从我们的池塘里滚出去，先生。约翰沮丧极了。然后我们的编剧詹·萨拉达分享说，格雷格·丹尼尔斯提出了那句台词，
have you ever tasted a rainbow? Oh my gosh, so brilliant. That was from Greg. It was even used in the promo that you played. They did have some alts like, have you ever tasted a smile? But ultimately, they kept the rainbow line. They also experimented with different things that Christians later could be doing on that line. Like, at one point, I guess they had him carrying around a giant basket of fruit. But they loved him picking up the sandwich. Yeah. I mean, they must have
你尝过彩虹的味道吗？噢天哪，太绝了。那是格雷格想出来的。它甚至被用在了你播放的宣传片里。他们确实也有一些备选台词，比如，你尝过微笑的味道吗？但最终，他们保留了关于彩虹的那句。他们还尝试了克里斯蒂安·史莱特在说这句台词时可以做的不同动作。比如，有一会儿，我猜他们让他抱着一大篮水果。但他们最喜欢的还是他捡起三明治。对啊。我的意思是，他们拍摄时一定
had so much fun shooting. They were just doing these weird absurd things. And Christian was playing it so straight the whole time. It's amazing. Well, in the entertainment weekly article, he did, the interviewer asked him if he ad-libbed anything, commenting that the thumbs-up at the end was classic. Oh, here was Christian's response. The thumbs-up was a spontaneous moment. I just kind of thought, what would be the cheesiest thing to do? John wanted it to really look like Kathy Bates, paid for this actor to come in and directed him on what to do behind the scenes.
玩得超级开心。他们只是在做这些奇怪荒诞的事情。而且克里斯蒂安全程都演得一本正经。这太棒了。嗯，在《娱乐周刊》的那篇报道中，采访者问他是否有即兴发挥，并评论说最后的竖大拇指非常经典。哦，克里斯蒂安是这样回应的。竖大拇指是一个即兴的动作。我当时只是在想，做什么事情是最俗气的？约翰希望看起来真的像是凯西·贝茨花钱请了这个演员来，并在幕后指导他该怎么做。
So I just kept thinking, what would Kathy Bates tell me to do? I love that motivation! Of course Kathy Bates is Joe Bennett. As Joe Bennett, exactly. Well, we had a fan question from Fiona L. in Melbourne, Australia. Our fan questions are very international today. Well, actually, Fiona has something to tell us, which is that Christian Slater does add very similar to the Saber introduction video.
所以我一直在想，凯西·贝茨会告诉我怎么做？我喜欢这个动机！凯西·贝茨当然就是乔·贝内特。作为乔·贝内特，没错。嗯，我们收到了来自澳大利亚墨尔本菲奥娜·L的粉丝提问。我们今天的粉丝提问非常具有国际化色彩。嗯，其实菲奥娜有件事要告诉我们，那就是克里斯蒂安·史莱特的广告拍得非常像萨博的介绍视频。
They are for HP Wolf Security. They seem very tongue-in-cheek, especially because he's done this saber video. I have never seen this commercial. I want to say thank you, Fiona, for sending me down the rabbit hole that is the Wolf HP web series. It was a web series that they launched in 2017, starring Christian Slater. They're called The Wolf. And I think Christian Slater is the wolf,
它们是为惠普“小狼”安全防护（HP Wolf Security）拍的。它们显得非常反讽，尤其是考虑到他还拍过这个萨博视频。我从来没看过这个广告。我要感谢菲奥娜，把我带进了惠普“小狼”网络剧这个无底洞。那是他们2017年推出的一部网络剧，由克里斯蒂安·史莱特主演。它们被称为“小狼”。而且我认为克里斯蒂安·史莱特就是那只狼，
because he howls in it. What? He howls. He walks through companies, kind of like he does in the Saber video, you know, like he walks through the conference room while a meeting is happening. And all the while he is highlighting how easily
因为他在里面会狼嚎。什么？他会狼嚎。他走过各大公司，有点像他在萨博视频里那样，你知道的，比如当会议正在进行时，他大摇大摆地穿过会议室。与此同时，他一直在强调
it would be for him to hack in to this company's printer or their computer. He sort of narrates as he's walking through, I pulled a clip. She never realizes a wolf around until it's too late. And they do exactly what the wolf expects them to do. They run into each other, and fall down. They become dinner. Time to eat. And fall down. They become dinner. I need to.
他黑进这家公司的打印机或电脑是多么轻而易举。他在走过的时候一边走一边解说，我剪辑了一段音频。人们直到为时已晚才意识到身边有一只狼。而他们做的正是这只狼所期望的。他们撞在一起，然后摔倒。他们成了晚餐。开饭时间到。然后摔倒。他们成了晚餐。我需要。
I've got no idea I use my phone to hack the OS and the printer over there. And why would they? Not one printer in this place has built in malware protection. Now, they're all busy watching a little something I threw up on the control panel. Just look at your screen. I can only accept all their print jobs until I find the info I'm looking for. Ooh, yeah, today's somebody's birthday. Perfect.
我完全不知道我用手机黑了那边的操作系统和打印机。他们怎么会知道呢？这里的每一台打印机都没有内置恶意软件防护。现在，他们都在忙着看我随手在控制面板上搞出来的一点小把戏。看着你们的屏幕就行。我只需要接受他们所有的打印作业，直到我找到我想要的信息。噢，对，今天有人过生日。太完美了。
A really good stuff is upstairs. The kind of stuff that could destroy any future this grand financial institution could hope to have. Oh! Do you hear all the sheep? No, I can't talk. They're because all those people, the workers, they're just sheep. They're just... Oh, my gosh.
真正的好东西在楼上。那种能够彻底摧毁这家宏伟金融机构未来所有希望的东西。哦！你听到所有的绵羊叫了吗？不，我不能说话。它们是因为所有人，那些工人们，他们只是绵羊。他们只是……噢，天哪。
And he's wool thing, you know? And then he howls! That is the most dramatic over-the-top corporate commercial I think I've ever heard. We only could hear it. Sam and I are dying laughing. We don't have a visual. Just like you guys listening. Oh my gosh.
还有他那身羊毛装扮，你知道吗？然后他狼嚎！这绝对是我听过的最具戏剧性、最夸张的企业商业广告了。我们只能听到声音。我和萨姆快笑死了。我们没有画面。就像你们这些收听节目的听众一样。噢，天哪。
Yeah. I mean, you guys, each one is a few minutes long. It was a whole series. Oh my gosh. And I love like really dramatically when he's like, they have no idea. I just hacked him. Yeah.
对。我的意思是，大家，每个视频都有好几分钟长。这是一个完整的系列。噢，天哪。而且我喜欢当他非常具有戏剧性地说，他们毫无所觉。我刚刚黑了他们。对。
To their phone. Well, listen, I didn't know that you could hack into a printer until I watched this video. That's what he's doing in this clip. He's acting for a printer. Anything can be hacked, guys. I learned something. And I guess they just re-up to this campaign.
进入他们的手机。好吧，听着，在我看这个视频之前，我根本不知道你可以黑进打印机里。这就是他在这个片段里做的事情。他在为打印机表演。任何东西都可以被黑客入侵，伙计们。我学到了一课。我猜他们刚刚重启了这个宣传活动。
So look for it. Well remember years ago when we found out that you could hack someone's camera in their computer and so then we started putting post-it notes over our cameras. Over our camera. I know everyone you should do that. You should put a post-it note over the little camera in your computer. Right. Are a piece of tape or what have you? Yes, because we read that article where you can hack
所以留意一下吧。好啦，还记得多年前当我们发现你可以黑进别人电脑里的摄像头时，然后我们就开始在摄像头上贴便签纸。贴在我们的摄像头上。我知道每个人都该这么做。你应该在电脑的小摄像头上贴一张便签。对。或者贴上一条胶带什么的？是的，因为我们读过那篇文章，说你可以黑入
into it and then people just watch you in your house. How creepy. That's creeps case. Super creeper. All right, so back to the conference room. Gabe has shown the video. People are digesting it. Gabe has shown the video, people are digesting it. Jim has sarcastic talking head about it. What a great impression by John Krasinski. Very good. Well, you know he's good at the impressions. Well, now Gabe is gonna explain that Saber primarily sells printers.
然后人们就可以在他们家里看着你。多毛骨悚然啊。太吓人了。超级变态。好了，回到会议室。加布播放了视频。大家正在消化吸收它。加布播放了视频，大家正在消化吸收它。吉姆对此发表了讽刺的单人采访。约翰·卡拉辛斯基的模仿太棒了。非常棒。嗯，你知道他很擅长模仿。好吧，现在加布要解释说萨博主要出售打印机。
So he wants everybody to consider themselves printer salesmen who also sell paper. Michael doesn't like this. He doesn't care for it. It's about to get worse for Michael though. Gabe then starts going over all the new company policies. At six minutes, 58 seconds, Meredith yells, talk about vacation days! Such a like odd heckle from Meredith.
所以他希望每个人都认为自己是兼卖纸张的打印机推销员。迈克尔不喜欢这样。他根本不在乎。不过对迈克尔来说，更糟糕的事还在后面。加布随后开始宣读所有公司的新政策。在6分58秒时，梅雷迪思大喊，说说假期天数吧！梅雷迪思发出了一个如此奇怪的起哄。
This was a much longer scene where everyone shares about their vacation days. And Jenna, it just cracked me up. I want to share a little bit with you. Meredith says, I saved up days from last year. I want to go to Jamaica. And then she stands up, rolls her hips and says, how Meredith got her groove back. Okay. Stanley has a talking head where he says, I need those vacation days. I have two women. One likes to ski and one likes the tropics. It's very difficult.
这是一个长得多的场景，每个人都分享了他们的假期天数。詹娜，这简直把我逗乐了。我想跟你分享一点。梅雷迪思说，我攒下了去年的假期。我想去牙买加。然后她站起来，扭动着臀部说，梅雷迪思是如何重拾自我的。好吧。斯坦利有一个单人采访，他说，我需要那些假期。我有两个女人。一个喜欢滑雪，一个喜欢热带。这太难了。
But I am not complaining or asking to be judged. I just need some time off. Okay. And then Michael says, what have you been saving up for days like a big trip in the future, like a 40-day family safari. Oh, Michael. Gabe says, I'm sorry, but maybe you could look into a two-week safari for your family. And Michael says, you can't take 12 kids on a safari in only two weeks. And Stanley says, you can't if they're imaginary. Oh, my God. And then Kelly explains, she actually owes the company days because she tried out for American
但我并没有抱怨，也没有要求别人评判我。我只是需要放个假。好吧。然后迈克尔说，你一直攒着假是为了什么未来的大旅行吗，比如为期40天的家庭野生动物园之旅。哦，迈克尔。加布说，我很抱歉，但也许你可以为你家人找一个两周的野生动物园之旅。迈克尔说，你不可能在短短两周内带着12个孩子去野生动物园。斯坦利说，如果它们是凭空想象的，你就不能。哦，天哪。然后凯利解释说，她其实还欠公司的假，因为她去参加了美国
Idol and took time off. She went to Atlanta, Boston, and Cincinnati, and she did not advance. These are amazing. I know, but here is my favorite part. This scene would have ended with a line from Creed and I am so bummed it got cut. While they're talking about their vacation time and whether it will roll over or not for Saber, Meredith sees the IT guy, right? Yes.
偶像（American Idol）的海选并请了假。她去了亚特兰大、波士顿和辛辛那提，但她没有晋级。这些太绝了。我知道，但这是我最喜欢的部门。这个场景本该以克里德的一句台词结束，我太懊恼它被剪掉了。当他们在谈论假期以及是否能结转到萨博时，梅雷迪思看到了IT小哥，对吧？是的。
And she says, hey, who the hell's going through our stuff? And Creed says, oh, that's just Sam. He's with me. What? And then Gabe goes, actually, that's Nick, your new IT guy. And then the scene progresses as aired. But I just love that Creed thought he knew this guy. He's like, oh, that's Sam. He's with me.
她说，嘿，到底是谁在翻我们的东西？克里德说，哦，那是萨姆。他跟我一块儿的。什么？然后加布说，其实，那是尼克，你们的新IT小哥。然后场景按播出的那样继续发展。但我就是喜欢克里德以为他认识这个人。他说，哦，那是萨姆。他跟我一起的。
Well, here is something that a lot of people flagged when we cut over to Nick, the new IT guy, many people noticed that it is the same person who was giving graphic design career advice to Pam at the job fair. Yeah. I asked Randy about this and he said, well, now job fair was not on his watch, but he did remember that a lot of the writers really, really loved this actor who, by the way, Nelson
好吧，这里有很多人在切到新IT小哥尼克时指出的一个细节，很多人注意到这个人就是之前在招聘会上给潘提供平面设计职业建议的那个人。是的。我问过兰迪这件事，他说，好吧，招聘会那会儿不在他的管辖范围内，但他确实记得很多编剧非常非常喜欢这个演员，顺便说一下，纳尔逊
Franklin, who previously appeared in Jobfare, and they just decided we don't care. We're going to bring him back because this is now an arc. He's going to appear in four episodes as Nick. He's really an amazing comedic actor. You've probably seen him on Black-ish, Veepe, Arrested Development, and Angela, you know him because you guys were both on Black-A-F together. We were.
富兰克林（Nelson Franklin）之前在招聘会里出现过，他们当时决定不管了。我们要把他带回来，因为这现在成了一条故事线。他将以尼克的身份出现在四集里。他真的是一个很棒的喜剧演员。你可能在《黑人当道》（Black-ish）、《副总统》（Veep）、《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）中见过他，安吉拉，你认识他因为你们俩一起演过《Black-A-F》。我们确实演过。
There was just the craziest little office reunion. Kin Co-op is directed our episode. Nelson and I played writers in a writer's room. It's so funny. So funny. And then Rashida placed Kenya's wife. And we all were there on the same day. Well, we had a blast.
那简直是办公室最疯狂的小聚会。金·科帕特（Ken Kwapis）导演了我们那一集。纳尔逊和我饰演编剧室里的编剧。太搞笑了。太搞笑了。然后拉什达（Rashida）饰演肯尼亚（Kenya）的妻子。我们那天都在同一天到场。总之我们玩得很开心。
Nelson's great. I was excited he got to come back. Me too. I really liked him. His character is going through our computers and he's gonna put up like blockers so that we can't waste time on certain websites. I mean, when he says YouTube,
纳尔逊人很好。我很兴奋他能回归。我也是。我真的很喜欢他。他的角色正在检查我们的电脑，他打算设置一些屏蔽程序，这样我们就不能在某些网站上浪费时间了。我的意思是，当他说YouTube时，
it looked like Michael pooped himself a little. Very upset. But wait, there's more. It doesn't stop there. Gabe has even more new policies. But before we do that, I think we should take a break. I need to use the restroom. Okay. You're not going to argue with me. I appreciate it. I will never argue with you for having to pee. You know this about me. It's one of our company policies. P whenever you need to. Go to the bathroom, you go to the bathroom. That's right.
看起来迈克尔好像有点拉裤兜了。非常沮丧。等等，还有呢。还没完。加布还有更多的新政策。但在我们做那件事之前，我想我们应该休息一下。我要去洗手间。好吧。你不会跟我争论的。我很感激。我永远不会因为你想尿尿而跟你争论。你了解我的。这是我们的公司政策之一。需要的时候就嘘嘘。去洗手间，你就去洗手间。没错。
We are back. My bladder is empty. Your bladder is empty night. Have a donut! So on brand for you, lady. Someone brought donuts today. It was my happiest moment of my day so far. But only half of it. You only ever eat half of anything. Well listen Gabe is in the conference room and his next new announcement is that he is going to give each employee an aluminum saber water bottle. This is is gonna eliminate the need for plastic, it's gonna be really good for the environment. But Michael is like upset. He's like, what about my little cups? Like my little cups, I drink the water out of.
我们回来了。我的膀胱空了。你的膀胱空了，女士。来个甜甜圈！太符合你的风格了，女士。今天有人带了甜甜圈。这是我今天目前为止最开心的时刻。但只吃了一半。你无论吃什么永远只吃一半。好吧，听着，加布在会议室里，他的下一个新公告是，他要给每个员工发一个铝制的萨博水瓶。这将消除对塑料的需求，对环境真的很好。但迈克尔不高兴了。他说，那我那些小杯子怎么办？就像我喝水用的那些小杯子。
He drinks 20 a day. Now here's the thing that I think is kind of brilliant, because Gabe says, I bet you can fit those 20 little cups into your water bottle. And Michael says, but what about the 20 little trips that I take to the water cooler each day where he scans the office or his 20 little conversations with Stanley?
他一天要喝20杯。现在这里有个我觉得有点绝妙的地方，因为加布说，我打赌你可以把那20个小杯子塞进你的水瓶里。迈克尔说，但我每天去饮水机那20趟怎么办，在那里他可以环视办公室，或者他跟斯坦利那20次小谈话怎么办？
Poor Stanley. Stanley's like, I can let go. All this time, Stanley, like unbeknownst to us, he's having 20 conversations a day with Michael because he sits by the water cooler. I'm surprised he hasn't moved the water cooler personally that Stanley didn't move it like back into the annex. Are, I'm surprised Stanley hasn't requested
可怜的斯坦利。斯坦利心想，我可以放过这一切。这么长时间以来，斯坦利，在不知不觉中，他每天跟迈克尔有20次谈话，因为他就坐在饮水机旁边。我很惊讶他居然没有亲自把饮水机搬走，我是说斯坦利没有把它搬回附楼。或者，我很惊讶斯坦利没有要求
to like trade seats with Creed. Truly. Well, he likes his relationship with Phyllis. We know that. That's his work, why? I just wanna say, I think his relationship with Phyllis. We know that. That's his work wife. I just want to say I think it's actually a little genius. The trip to the water cooler as a managerial technique. I was like, oh, smart. If Michael really wanted to manage people, he just gets bored. That's true. It's probably driven from another place.
跟克里德换座位。真的。好吧，他喜欢和菲莉丝的关系。我们都知道。那是他的工作夫妻。我只想说，我觉得这其实有点天才。把去饮水机当成一种管理技巧。当时我想，哦，真聪明。如果迈克尔真的想管理员工，他只是觉得无聊。确实如此。这可能是出于别的原因。
Well, at seven minutes, 28 seconds, if you look at the saber water bottle, that was made by clean canteen. Oh, a little tidbit from Randy Cordray. And they also applied the logo that was designed by Henry Sain. I guess there were many, many variations of the saber logo that Greg and Paul had to choose from, and that's the one they picked. But Jenna, yeah. The whole time I was watching the scene,
好吧，在7分28秒时，如果你看一下那个萨博水瓶，那是克林肯藤（Clean Canteen）制造的。哦，来自兰迪·科德瑞（Randy Cordray）的一个小花絮。他们还印上了由亨利·赛因（Henry Sain）设计的标志。我猜格雷格和保罗有非常非常多种萨博标志的变体可供选择，这就是他们挑选的那一个。但是詹娜，是的。我看着这个场景的全程，
all I could remember was we did this. We did this! Yes, Paul Lieberstein made us all drink out of these canteen. Yes, and I was like, wait, I know I have something in my digital clutter about this some email saying that we were getting rid of plastic water bottles I knew I had something in my digital clutter about this. Sam? Angela's digital clutter.
我能记住的只有，我们做过这个。我们做过这个！是的，保罗·利伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein）让我们所有人都用这些水壶喝水。是的，当时我想，等等，我知道我的数码杂物堆里有关于这个事情的邮件，说我们要取消塑料水瓶，我知道我的数码杂物堆里有关于这个。萨姆？安吉拉的数码杂物堆。
Oh my god. So Jenna, we all got an email during this time that there wouldn't be plastic water bottles on set, that we were all getting a stainless steel water bottle that said dunder-miffling on it. Yep. And we were gonna refill them throughout the day. So, Jenna, you remembered so quickly it was Paul. I could remember if it was Paul or Brent
哦天哪。所以詹娜，我们大家当时都收到了一封邮件，说片场将不再提供塑料水瓶，我们所有人都会得到一个印有邓德米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）字样的不锈钢水瓶。没错。而且我们整天都可以去加满水。所以，詹娜，你记性真好，马上就想到了是保罗。我当时想不起来到底是保罗还是布伦特（Brent），
because I remember Brent was very much about being healthy and eco-friendly. Yes. I texted Brent. Brent was this you. He was like, no, I'm pretty sure it was Paul. So then I emailed Paul and I said, Paul, I know we did this, right? I found in my digital clutter was this your idea?
因为我记得布伦特非常注重健康和环保。是的。我给布伦特发了短信。布伦特，这是你搞的吗？他说，不，我确信是保罗。然后我给保罗发邮件说，保罗，我知道我们做过这事对吧？我在我的数码杂物堆里发现，这是你的主意吗？
And was it also part of the inspiration for Gabe and his saber water bottles? And this is what Paul had to say. Paul said, yes, I tried to get us to be plastic free. It worked for a little while. I remember that too. It was very short list. I know. He said, as far as it being an intended storyline for Gabe, he doesn't have a clear memory that that was specifically a Gabe storyline, but in general, so much of what was happening around us was inspiration for the show. All right. It was probably connected, but I was like, oh my gosh, we did this. Do you know what I remembered?
这也是加布和他的萨博水瓶的灵感来源之一吗？保罗是这么说的。保罗说，是的，我曾试图让我们做到无塑料。这管用了一段时间。我也记得那个。那是个很短的清单。我知道。他说，至于它是否是加布预定的故事情节，他记不清那具体是不是一个关于加布的故事线，但总的来说，我们周围发生的大量事情都是这部剧的灵感来源。好吧。它可能是有联系的，但当时我想，哦天哪，我们真的做过这个。你知道我记得什么吗？
What? Standing in line to refill it. There literally was a line. Yes. Well, you know, Paul told me that this was sort of a craze that was happening during this time. Companies were really trying to limit plastic use, and so he wanted us to be a part of that, you know?
什么？排队去加水。那里真的排起了长队。是的。好吧，你知道的，保罗告诉我，这有点像是当时风靡一时的一种狂热。各大公司都在极力限制塑料的使用，所以他想让我们也成为其中的一部分，你知道的？
I do think it's a great idea, but I think you need more than one refill jug area. That probably would have helped. That would have helped. Well, Michael has a talking head about all this, where he says, okay, there's a small part of him that's excited about the new company, but 70% of him is water. And at the end of this talking head,
我确实觉得这是个好主意，但我觉得你需要不止一个加水区。那可能会有帮助。那确实会有帮助。好吧，迈克尔关于这一切有一个单人采访，在采访中他说，好吧，他有一小部分人为新公司感到兴奋，但他的70%是水。在这个单人采访的结尾，
he says that he thinks these changes suck ball. Because you know what he was gonna say. Sucks balls, it was so funny. I guess cutting off the end of Michael, saying balls was an idea that John had. He came up with it in editing with Dave Rogers, and I love their take on this. What they were saying was that obviously Michael completed his sentence,
他说他觉得这些改变“操蛋（sucks ball）”。因为你知道他本来要说什么。Sucks balls（操蛋），太搞笑了。我猜掐掉迈克尔说“balls”的结尾是约翰提出的一个想法。他和戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers）在剪辑时想出了这个点子，我非常喜欢他们的这种处理方式。他们想表达的是，很明显迈克尔把句子说完了，
but they imagined that when the documentary aired, that the documentarians would have left in all of the footage, but the network running the documentary would have to in all of the footage, but the network running the documentary would have to cut it off. Right, because of, you know, standards and practices, and he said they based that on the amount of times that we had to cut things or changed things because of standards and practices.
但他们想象着，当纪录片播出时，纪录片制作人会保留所有的素材，但运营纪录片的电视网将不得不剪掉它。对，因为你知道的，审查和规范（Standards and Practices），他说他们是根据我们因为审查和规范而不得不剪掉或更改内容的次数来决定的。
Every episode probably. Very realistic. Well, listen, Angela, you mentioned the line to fill their water bottles. And while Michael is in line, Toby's getting water and it runs out. Toby says we kicked it. Which cracked me up. Me too. I wrote it down at eight minutes, 45 seconds.
每一集大概都是如此。非常现实。好吧，听着，安吉拉，你提到了排队加水的事。就在迈克尔排队的时候，托比在接水，结果水喝光了。托比说我们把它喝光了（kicked it）。这把我逗乐了。我也是。我在8分45秒时把它记下来了。
That's what you say when a keg runs out, right? I know. Well, what does that tell us about Toby? Well, I think what does it tell us about Paul? Because I've bought a pony keg with Paul, and we've kicked it. See, I would never use that language because I've never purchased a keg, and I've never had a beer out of a keg. Oh, man.
当一个小酒桶见底时，你就会这么说，对吧？我知道。好吧，这向我们透露了关于托比的什么信息？嗯，我觉得这向我们透露了关于保罗的什么信息？因为我和保罗买过一个小酒桶，而且我们把它喝光了。你看，我永远不会用这种语言，因为我从来没买过酒桶，也从来没从酒桶里喝过啤酒。哦，天哪。
I'm not a beer person. Listen. Now, I'll do a flavored ale, or a cider beer. A really, really cold keg, and like getting a beer out of a super cold keg. It's great, especially like on a hot day. Maybe you put one, you know, at second base, because you're playing softball with friends, and if you make it to second base, you get a beer, and you get a little tooted while you're waiting to run into home plate. That cold beer out of a keg, it's amazing.
我不是个爱喝啤酒的人。听着。现在，我会喝点调味艾尔啤酒，或者苹果酒。一个非常非常冰镇的酒桶，从超冷的酒桶里接一杯啤酒。这太棒了，特别是比如在热天的时候。也许你把它放在二垒附近，因为你在跟朋友打垒球，如果你跑到了二垒，你就能喝上一杯啤酒，在等待跑回本垒的过程中你还能有点微醺。那从酒桶里接出的冰啤酒，简直棒极了。
I mean, that sounds miserable to me. You drink some beer and then you have to run on your sloshy beer stomach. Have you seen like co-ed softball, like with a group of friends? There's, this is not like real athleticism. That I haven't lived. You've had all these experiences.
我的意思是，这听起来对我来说简直糟透了。你喝了点啤酒，然后你还得挺着个充满液体晃荡的啤酒肚跑步。你见过男女混合垒球赛吗，就跟一群朋友一起那种？这里，这根本不是什么真正的运动天赋。我还没过过这种生活。你经历过所有这些。
And to me, it's like you lived in a foreign land. What a foreign land of softball and beer? Yeah. I have no like frame of reference for that. I know you and Lee bond over the stuff all the time. Is this a Texas thing? I mean, I'm sure we're doing it in Missouri. No, it was.
而在我看来，就像你生活在一个异国他乡。垒球和啤酒的异国他乡？对。我对此没有任何参照框架。我知道你和李经常因为这些事情产生共鸣。这是德克萨斯的风俗吗？我的意思是，我确信我们在密苏里州也会这么做。不，确实是。
What was I doing during this time? This was just like a hip young person out in the world. I've never been a hip young person. Well, that's true. I've been a 65 year old woman since the day I was born. It's true. And I love you for it. Thank you, lady. As I stare at your big fake flower that's on your lapel. I know it's not working. I know it's not working. I wore it in today because I wanted to prove to you that this cannot happen on our book launch tour. It can't look at me. It's ridiculous. You never had his water coming out of this flower. Squirt, squirt. It's borderline clownish. It can't happen. You never had to prove it to me.
我当时在干什么？这就像是一个在世界上闯荡的时髦年轻人。我从来都不是一个时髦的年轻人。好吧，这倒也是。我从出生那天起就是一个65岁的老太太了。确实如此。我爱你这一点。谢谢你，女士。当我凝视着你翻领上那朵巨大的假花时。我知道它没用。我知道它没用。我今天戴着它是为了向你证明，在我们的新书签售巡回之旅中绝不能发生这种事。它不行，看看我。太荒谬了。你从来不用从这朵花里喷出水来。滋，滋。这近乎小丑般的滑稽。这绝不能发生。你从来不用向我证明这一点。
I've known it from the beginning. Well, I needed to prove it to myself. All right. Where are we? Well, Toby has just kicked the water cooler. Oh, yes, that's right. Well, now Michael's going to confront Gabe. He's going to say, listen, I don't mean to seem ungrateful, but I am really struggling to embrace some of these changes, such as all of them. Gabe says it's kind of above his pay grade. He can't really change any of the policies, but he'll see what he can do. And now, Pam and Jim are going to enter the daycare center. All of these scenes were absolutely delicious. I loved watching them.
我从一开始就知道。好吧，我需要向自己证明这一点。好了，我们到哪儿了？好吧，托比刚把饮水机的水喝光了。哦，对，没错。好吧，现在迈克尔要去找加布对质了。他打算说，听着，我不是想显得不知感恩，但我真的很艰难地去接受其中一些改变，比如所有这些改变。加布说这超出了他的权限范围。他真的没法改变任何政策，但他会看看他能做些什么。现在，潘和吉姆要走进日托中心了。所有这些场景简直太美妙了。我太喜欢看它们了。
We had a fan question from Alice are in Italy. Where did you shoot the daycare scenes? Was it a real daycare? Did you make any changes? Lady, did you recognize it? No. Okay. Well, it's called Sandbox Daycare. We made that up. That's not even a real daycare in Scranton. We shot this at Peacaboo Playland in Eagle Rock, California. Didanton. We shot this at Peekaboo Playland in Eagle Rock, California. Did you not take Isabel to Peekaboo Playland? Was that after she was a toddler?
我们收到了来自意大利阿尔斯的粉丝提问。你们在哪里拍的日托场景？那是真正的日托中心吗？你们做过什么改动吗？女士，你认出来了吗？没有。好吧，它叫沙盒日托（Sandbox Daycare）。那是我们编出来的。那在斯克兰顿甚至都不是一家真正的日托中心。我们是在加利福尼亚州鹰岩的躲猫猫游乐园（Peekaboo Playland）拍摄的。迪丹顿。我们是在加利福尼亚州鹰岩的躲猫猫游乐园拍摄的。你没带伊莎贝尔去过躲猫猫游乐园吗？那是她过了幼儿期之后吗？
This was all the rage when my kids were little. Eagle Rock's far from me. I guess that's true. We had tons and tons of playland type places right by me, so I never needed to venture this far. Well, you know, when I did this episode, I didn't have kids, but then when I was rewatching it, I was like, it's peekaboo. It's peekaboo, Blaleighand. I've spent so many days in this space.
当我孩子们小的时候，这简直风靡一时。鹰岩离我很远。我想也是吧。我离我近的地方有成吨成吨的这种游乐园类型的场所，所以我从来不需要跑这么远。好吧，你知道的，当我拍这一集的时候，我还没有孩子，但后来当我重温它的时候，我想，这是躲猫猫。这是躲猫猫，布莱兰。我在这个地方度过了好几天。
See, the one by me is the coop. I spent all the time with the coop. I've been to the coop. Yeah. All right. So there's a big twirly slide in the middle. There's like a tree house around the curly slide. It's the cutest dang thing. When we get there, Jim and Pam are totally charmed, except Jim accidentally walks in on the daycare director who is using the little kitty toilet. Those toilets are so low to the ground.
看，离我近的那个叫“合作社”（The Coop）。我所有的精力和“合作社”耗在一起了。我去过合作社。是的。好吧。中间有一个巨大的旋转滑梯。旋转滑梯周围还有一个树屋。这简直是最可爱的玩意儿了。当我们到达那里时，吉姆和潘完全被迷住了，除了吉姆不小心撞见了正在使用小猫咪马桶的日托园长。那些马桶离地面太低了。
Well, they need to be because the little children. I know, but seeing a grown man on it really did. I was like, oh my god. John Sennason, an audio clip of what it was like to shoot in the daycare. Here's what he had to say. My other favorite memory from that episode was the interview with the daycare center. Jenna, as we've talked about many times and I won't bear to see you on your own show, I apologize but not really. Truly some of my favorite, favorite memories in all of my career were getting to do scenes with you period, but especially those scenes where the two of us were sort of stuck in it together, that we were both in something that we had to get out of together.
嗯，因为小孩子们，它们必须那么低。我知道，但看到一个成年男人坐在上面真的。当时我想，哦天哪。约翰发来了一段关于在日托中心拍摄是什么体验的音频剪辑。他是这么说的。我对那一集的另一个最爱记忆就是日托中心的面试。詹娜，正如我们多次讨论过的那样，我不会在你的节目里喧宾夺主，我道歉但也不是真的道歉。老实说，我整个职业生涯中一些最最美好的记忆，就是能和你演对手戏，尤其是我们俩某种程度上被困在其中、必须一起摆脱某种困境的那些场景。
I remember very specifically your line reading when I came out from seeing Jerry in the bathroom, and I said, I just saw someone in the bathroom, and you very earnestly ask, who was it, who was it, and then you quickly digress as your brain realizes, oh, it was definitely the guy that we're about to interview. And your line reading of, who was it, who was it, was it the guy who's going to interview us?
我清楚地记得，当我从洗手间看完杰瑞出来时你的台词语气，我说，我刚刚看到洗手间里有人，然后你非常认真地问，是谁，是谁，然后当你的大脑意识到，哦，绝对是我们即将面试的那个人时，你迅速岔开了话题。你念“是谁，是谁，是那个要面试我们的人吗”的语气，
It was so funny. And I don't know that I had a good enough take of my reaction to you. In fact, do I physically bail out after you say that to me? Man, that really made me laugh. I seem to remember going through, I don't know, 10-12 takes of just not being able to keep it together. That was a total gigolfest day for me. You were always more professional, but I was in full gigolfest mode. And shout out to my friend Joey Slotnik, who played Jerry. I was so excited to get him on the show and he absolutely crushed it. That gesture he does in the bathroom where he silently raises his hand, but there is no there is nothing said between the two people.
太搞笑了。而且我不知道自己当时对你的反应演得够不够好。事实上，在你对我说了那句话之后，我真的从现场落荒而逃了吗？天哪，那真的让我笑死。我依稀记得拍了大概，不知道，10到12条，就是完全控制不住自己。对我来说，那天简直就是狂笑节。你一直以来都更加专业，但我当时完全进入了狂笑模式。向我的朋友乔伊·斯洛特尼克（Joey Slotnik）致敬，他在剧中饰演杰瑞（Jerry）。我当时很高兴能邀请他来参演这部剧，而他的表现绝对惊艳。他在洗手间里做的那个手势，无声地举起手，但两人之间却没有任何对话。
Just utter shame and embarrassment and guilt. He was so great on that show and I just remember yet again just getting to watch those scenes and not have to give any notes. yet again, just getting to watch those scenes and not have to give any notes. All right. So I just have to say, I totally remember that. Yes, John, you do physically bail out of the scene. But also, you know what? I really appreciate him saying that he liked shooting these scenes with me because I think there's often a lot written about our romantic chemistry on screen. But we had a really special comedic chemistry together, and I feel like this storyline really highlights that. We were great partners all around.
只有无尽的羞耻、尴尬和内疚。他在那部剧里的表现太棒了，而且我只记得自己再次坐在那儿看这些场景，完全不需要给出任何笔记。再次提醒，只是坐在那儿看这些场景，完全不需要给出任何笔记。好吧。所以我必须说，我完全记得那件事。是的，约翰，你确实从那个场景里落荒而逃了。但话说回来，你知道吗？我真的很感激他说他喜欢和我一起拍这些场景，因为我认为关于我们在银幕上的浪漫化学反应，外界往往有很多报道。但我们俩之间有一种非常特殊的喜剧化学反应，我觉得这条故事线真正突显了这一点。我们在各方面都是绝佳的搭档。
I agree, and I loved what John said about when you guys were both in a sticky situation together. Yes, I loved it. And, you know, John mentioned Jerry the daycare director was played by Joey Slotnik. He was a really good friend of John's. He had also been in John's movie, brief interviews with hideous men.
我完全同意，而且我特别喜欢约翰说的，当你们俩同时陷入尴尬处境的时候。没错，我太喜欢了。而且，你知道的，约翰提到日托中心主任杰瑞是由乔伊·斯洛特尼克饰演的。他是约翰非常好的朋友。他之前还演过约翰的电影《性k过敏儿》（Brief Interviews with Hideous Men）。
But Joey had actually auditioned for this part through Alice and Jones. I guess he'd auditioned for other roles on the show. And when this role came up, she thought of him. And she knew he was John Sprint. But you might recognize Joey from the TV shows, Aelius Boston Public, the single guy, or Nip Tuck. He was also in the movie's Twister
但乔伊其实是通过爱丽丝和琼斯（Alice and Jones）来为这个角色试镜的。我猜他以前也为剧中的其他角色试镜过。当这个角色出现时，她就想到了他。而且她知道他是约翰的朋友。不过你可能从这些电视剧里认出乔伊：《艾莉·麦克拜尔》（Ally McBeal）、《波士顿公立学校》（Boston Public）、《单身汉》（The Single Guy）或者《整容室》（Nip/Tuck）。他还演过电影《龙卷风》
and the Secret Life of Walter Middey, which by the way is one of my favorite movies directed by Ben Stiller. Well, I met Joey years ago. When I first came to Los Angeles, my friend got me a job just for one season being a stand-in on the single guy. I didn't know you were a stand-in.
以及《白日梦想家》（The Secret Life of Walter Mitty），顺便说一句，那是我最喜欢的本·斯蒂勒（Ben Stiller）导演的电影之一。好吧，我几年前就认识乔伊了。当我刚来洛杉矶时，我的朋友帮我找了一份工作，仅仅在一个季度里担任《单身汉》的替身演员。我不知道你当过替身演员。
Yeah, just for one season. Still, it was so cool. What a great way to learn the ins and out of a four-camera show. Yes, you know, I did background work for years when I first came out. Same, a great way to just sit on a set and observe how it works. So by the time I finally booked a role and I had a line,
对，就一个季度。不过，真的很酷。这真是了解四机拍摄节目内幕的绝佳方式。没错，你知道的，我刚出道时做了好几年的背景演员。我也是，这绝对是坐在片场观察它是如何运作的好方法。所以当我终于接到一个角色并且有台词时，
I was like, oh, I know the flow. Like I know some of the language. I know this world. And in four camera stand-ins walk through the role while they're lighting. They say the lines that go to the mark, it was such a great education. And Joey was so nice to everyone. That's my memory of him. Well, we got some mail asking, why aren't there any
我就想，哦，我了解这个节奏。比如我懂一些专业术语。我了解这个世界。在四机拍摄中，替身演员会在打光时走位排练。他们说出台词并走到定点，这真是一次极好的教育。而且乔伊对每个人都超级好。这是我对他的记忆。好吧，我们收到了一些邮件，问为什么这里没有
kids at this daycare? Right. Well, there actually were. The kids were staged doing a little story time, but they were over to the side. So when Pam and Jim arrive, there was a, like a mini scene of the kids doing story time. and Pam and Jim have a little awe moment. And then John actually directed me when he was gonna walk to the bathroom to go up to the little T set and just be like pretending like I was a kid doing T and I was like so charmed. And Jen shared that they really like just following me and John rather than cutting away and showing the kids. So they actually edited out that story time bit for time
日托中心里怎么没有小孩子？对。其实是有的。小孩子们被安排在进行一小段故事时间，但他们被安排在旁边。所以当潘和吉姆到达时，本来有一段类似于孩子们进行故事时间的微型场景，
because they just liked staying with our enthusiasm over the daycare center. Oh yeah, I agree. You guys are just so delighted to be new parents. And I loved the line when Jim says, oh, Cubbies, I forgot about cubbies. Yes. Because that's really how it is when you have kids, all of these memories come back to you. It's true. Well, right after this gym and Pam scene at the daycare
潘和吉姆会有一个小小的“哦”的感叹时刻。然后约翰甚至指导我，当他假装要走向洗手间时，走到那个小茶具布景旁，假装自己是个在喝茶的小孩，我当时觉得太迷人了。简分享说，他们其实更喜欢只跟随我和约翰，而不是切镜头去展示孩子们。所以他们最终为了控制时长，剪掉了那段故事时间，
would have been the second part of this accounting runner. The one where Angela's giving fake work to Kevin. Yes. I love it. All right. So it reads, interior, advance refrigeration. Kevin approaches a desk where an older man is sitting. Kevin, excuse me, are you Todd? The old man says yes. Kevin says, I'm Kevin.
因为他们更喜欢专注于我们对日托中心的兴奋之情。哦，对，我同意。你们俩看起来简直太高兴成为新父母了。我特别喜欢吉姆说的那句台词：“哦，小格子柜，我都快忘这玩意儿了。”没错。因为当你有孩子的时候，真实情况确实如此，所有这些记忆都会涌上心头。确实如此。好吧，就在吉姆和潘在日托中心的这场戏之后，
I'm an accountant at Dundermiflin. Todd says, oh, you must know Phyllis. She's great. Kevin says, Phyllis is, but I didn't come all the way over here to talk about Phyllis. Kevin closes the door on the cameras. What's happening? What's happening?
本该是会计部门支线剧情的第二部分。也就是安吉拉给凯文安排假工作的那个情节。没错。我太喜欢了。好吧，内容是这样的：内景，进阶制冷公司。凯文走到一张桌子前，一个老头正坐在那儿。凯文：“打扰一下，你是托德吗？”老头说是的。凯文说：“我是凯文。
Dun dun dun dun. Dun dun dun. Wow. I know, part three is coming up. Well, this is the part of the show where we're gonna see Andy and Aaron flirting in the kitchen. So awkward.
我是邓德米夫林的会计。”托德说：“哦，你一定认识菲莉丝。她人很好。”凯文说：“菲莉丝是挺好，但我可不是大老远跑过来跟你聊菲莉丝的。”凯文在摄像机前关上了门。发生什么事了？发生什么事了？
So awkward. I wanted to point out that I really loved how during the scene, Andy pulls a pizza out of the fridge and it's in an Alfredo's pizza cafe pizza box. You know Phil Shae was all over that? It's the details. I know.
咚咚咚咚。咚咚咚。哇。我知道，第三部分要来啦。好吧，这是剧里我们要看到安迪和艾琳在厨房调情的环节。太尴尬了。
It's in the details, the prop protégé in me. Hmm, notice these things. Saw that. Yes. I'm learning. I'm always learning. You're always learning. The next scene between Gabe and Joe Bennett
超级尴尬。我想指出的是，我真的很喜欢在这场戏中，安迪从冰箱里拿出一个披萨，那是一个阿尔弗雷多披萨咖啡馆（Alfredo's Pizza Cafe）的披萨盒。你知道菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）对这个有多上心吧？细节决定成效。我知道。
on the computer is so good. And we meet Joe Bennett. Yes. Randy told me that we shot this in real time. No way. Yes, they set up a little Joe's office set right outside our main office stage. It's where our lunch tables would normally be.
细节决定成效，作为道具界高材生的我。嗯，注意到了这些细节。看到了。是的。我在学习。我一直在学习。你一直在学习。盖布和乔·贝内特（Jo Bennett）之间的下一场戏，
We shot it using Skype. Remember Skype? Yeah. It was like the first Zoom. I remember this because Pam did some of these Skype's when she was at art school. And this internet at our studio could be really troublesome. And Randy told me they had to create an entirely new network
在电脑上的那段简直太棒了。我们见到了乔·贝内特。对。兰迪告诉我，我们是用实时镜头拍摄的。不会吧。真的，他们在我们主办公布景的右侧搭建了一个小小的乔的办公室布景。那通常是我们摆午餐桌的地方。
just to make this Skype work with Kathy Bates. And everyone in the cast and crew had to turn off their computers and put their phones on airplane mode. Just to get the signal strong enough. Yes, otherwise it would break up. I totally remember that. Well, during this scene, Michael is lurking behind the laptop and eventually Gabe is going to turn the computer around and Joe Bennett is going to be like, what's up? Yeah, hey, fella.
我们是用Skype拍摄的。还记得Skype吗？对。它就像最早的Zoom。我记得这个，因为潘在艺术学校时就用Skype做过一些视频连线。而且我们工作室的互联网有时候真的很让人头疼。兰迪告诉我，他们不得不创建一个全新的网络，
She kind of tries to whistle. It's not a full whistle. It's not a full whistle. It's okay, though. Michael says that he doesn't want to do these changes, but Joe says she hasn't seen a company this poorly managed since her grandson Snowball company. Michael says, you know what? Maybe I could speak to Christian Slater.
只为了让这个Skype能和凯西·贝茨（Kathy Bates）顺利连线。演员和剧组里的每个人都不得不关掉他们的电脑，把手机调成飞行模式。只为了让信号足够强。没错，否则画面就会中断。我完全记得。好吧，在这场戏中，迈克尔潜伏在笔记本电脑后面，最后盖布转过电脑，乔·贝内特就会说：“怎么啦？”对啊，嘿，伙计。
I bet he would know what to do. Michael, come on. I mean, Michael, do you think Christian Slater is there? He's not there, Michael. He thinks he now works with Christian Slater. He does. He's imagining the Christmas party. Yeah.
她试图吹口哨。那不算是一个完整的口哨。那不是个完整的口哨。不过没关系。迈克尔说他不想做这些改动，但乔说她从她孙子的雪球公司倒闭以来，就没见过管理得这么糟糕的公司。迈克尔说：“你知道吗？也许我可以和克里斯蒂安·史莱特（Christian Slater）谈谈。
Joe says, why don't you take till the end of the day to decide if you can apply these changes? And Michael's like, I don't need to think about it. I know I can't. And then she says, I think you should take till the end of the day. And then it becomes very clear that if the answer isn't yes, he'll be far out. He'll be far out. Yeah.
我打赌他会知道该怎么做。”迈克尔，拜托。我是说，迈克尔，你觉得克里斯蒂安·史莱特在那里吗？他不在那儿，迈克尔。他以为他现在跟克里斯蒂安·史莱特一起工作。他确实是这么想的。他在脑补圣诞派对的事。对。
God, it's some great managing. I mean, I just, I know. Joe Bennett is your kindred spirit. It's true. Michael's gonna drive out of the parking lot, but not before he tosses his aluminum sabre water bottle out the window. Yes, and it hits Stanley's windshield.
乔说：“你为什么不利用到今天结束的时间来决定自己能不能接受这些改动？”迈克尔却说：“我不需要考虑。我知道我接受不了。”然后她说：“我觉得你应该考虑一整天。”接着情况变得非常明显，如果答案不是“好的”，他就要彻底完蛋了。他就要彻底完蛋了。对。
Of course. I asked Randy Cordray, how did we do this broken window gag? And he said that the windshield was pre-broken. I don't know if you notice, but you don't ever see the water bottle hit the windshield. You hear it, and then he drives by and you see it's broken. They did that because it was just too hard for Steve to like throw a water bottle with such force that it would actually crack a windshield. And accuracy, if we learned anything
天哪，这管理手段太高明了。我是说，我真的，我知道。乔·贝内特简直是你的灵魂伴侣。确实如此。迈克尔将把车开出停车场，但在那之前，他要把自己铝制的萨博（Sabre）水瓶从车窗扔出去。没错，而且正好砸中了斯坦利的挡风玻璃。
about that watermelon on the trampoline. Oh my gosh, so many takes of watermelons. Randy said they just added a sound effect in post-production and it really works. Back at the daycare, Jerry, the daycare director is going to introduce himself. Oh my gosh, Jenna, John's performance is so good in this scene. Of course he gives Pam a look like, yeah, that's the guy.
当然。我问过兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray），我们是怎么拍这个打破玻璃的恶作剧的？他说挡风玻璃是提前弄碎的。我不知道你们有没有注意到，你从来没看到水瓶真正砸中挡风玻璃。你听到声音，然后他开车经过，你就看到玻璃碎了。他们之所以这么做，是因为要让史蒂夫用足够的力量扔一个水瓶去真正砸裂挡风玻璃实在太难了。还有准确度，如果我们从
That's the one I walked in on. And he cannot pull it together. He keeps putting his foot in his mouth. Jerry goes to take a call and Pam's like, listen, you need to get it together. So John said that he doesn't remember giving any pieces of direction, but he did give me a piece of direction in this scene. And it was so delighted to get it. He said that I should try saying that line. And that's the most awkward solution to the problem, like a game show host might say it. Oh, isn't that a fun thing to play with?
蹦床上的那个西瓜学到了什么的话。噢天哪，拍西瓜拍了太多次了。兰迪说他们只是在后期制作中加了音效，效果真的很棒。回到日托中心，日托中心主任杰瑞要作自我介绍。天哪，珍娜，约翰在这场戏里的表演太棒了。他当然给了潘一个眼神，好像在说：“没错，就是这家伙。
It is, and it was very not sort of what Pam normally sounds like. I loved it. I did too. I thought it was so funny. So let's continue on here. And Pam and Jim are going to be sitting in Jerry's office and they're having their interview. Oh my God, the scene is so good.
就是我闯进去的那个人。”而且他根本控制不住自己。他总是祸从口出。杰瑞去接个电话，潘就说：“听着，你得振作起来。”所以约翰说他记不清自己有没有给出过任何导演指导，但在这场戏里他确实给了我一个指导。而且我听到时太高兴了。他说我应该试着用那种台词语气来说。那就像是一个游戏节目主持人可能会说的话，可以说是面对这种困境时最尴尬的解决办法。哦，尝试这种演法不是挺有意思的吗？
It's so funny. It's so funny. Everyone plays every moment perfectly. Jim is gonna ask about switching some holiday time. Yeah, what's their flexibility when it comes to vacation time? And Jerry says, you know what? If you get in, we can discuss that. And Pam is like,
确实很有意思，而且这非常不像是潘平时说话的语气。我很喜欢。我也很喜欢。我觉得太搞笑了。那我们接着往下看。然后潘和吉姆将坐在杰瑞的办公室里接受面试。天哪，这场戏太棒了。
is this because he walked in on you in the bathroom? She just calls it out. She just, she does exactly what Jim was going to do. And she was like, no, no, don't do that. That'd be awkward. But clearly it needs to be said, right? I'm with Pam here. And Jerry's like, you told her like Jim and Jerry don't even know each other, but Jim broke some guy code. I know. I love it because Pam is like, I mean, it seems like this isn't going well,
太搞笑了。每个人把每个时刻都演得完美无缺。吉姆要询问关于调换一些节假日时间的事。对，他们关于假期时间的弹性是怎样的？然后杰瑞说：“你知道吗？如果你被录取了，我们可以讨论这个。”潘就说：
but it should be going well because we're really nice people. And Jerry says, you know what? Have you ever considered that you're not as charming as you think you are? Ouch. Wow. Ouch. And Pam's like, no. Pam's like, I think we are as charming as we think you are? Ouch. Wow. Ouch. And Pam's like, no.
“这是因为他刚才在洗手间撞见你了吗？”她直接当面说出来了。她直接就这么做了，她做了吉姆本来想做的事。她当时想，不，不，别这么做。那样太尴尬了。但很显然这事必须说出来，对吧？我站在潘这边。而杰瑞的反应是，你告诉她的样子就像吉姆和杰瑞根本不认识彼此一样，但吉姆确实打破了某种男人的潜规则。我知道。我太喜欢了，因为潘说：“我的意思是，这看起来进展不太顺利，
Pam's like, I think we are as charming as we think we are. And Jim's like, why didn't you just lock the door? Yeah. And he's like, there's no lock because of the kids. Well, I'll have you know I've been in that bathroom at that daycare center. There is a lock, it's up real high. Right.
但它本该进展顺利的，因为我们真的是很好的人。”杰瑞却说：“你知道吗？你有没有想过，你们其实并没有自己想象的那么有魅力？”扎心。哇。扎心。潘的反应是：“没有。潘的意思是，我觉得我们就是像自己想象的那么有魅力？扎心。哇。扎心。潘的反应是：没有。
That's what you do. Right. You put it up real high. That they can's what you do. Right. You put it up real high that they can't reach it. My all-time daycare favorite moment might be at the end of the scene when Jim says Anyone could have walked in there and Jerry just goes story time Story time is when Jerry poops every day. Yeah. No one's around. No one's coming in during time. It's story time. It's story time. Well, have you know at 15 minutes, 25 seconds,
潘的反应是：我觉得我们就是像自己想象的那么有魅力。然后吉姆说：“你当时为什么不锁门呢？”对。然后他说：“因为小孩子在，所以没有锁。”好吧，我得告诉你，我确实去过那个日托中心的洗手间。里面其实是有锁的，位置安得很高。对。
you can see kids out the door over John's shoulder. So they are there. Just proof of child. Proof of child. Also, this whole storyline of Jim walking in on the guy in the bathroom was based on a real life moment. This is so good, Jenna, you have to tell it. From our writer, Halstead Sullivan.
就该这么做。对。你把它安得高高的。对，就该这么做。对。你把它安得高高的，他们够不着。我一直以来最喜欢的日托中心笑点，可能就是在这场戏的结尾，吉姆说“任何人当时都有可能走进去”，而杰瑞直接接了一句：“故事时间。故事时间就是杰瑞每天拉臭臭的时间。没错。周围没有人。在那个时间没有人会进来。那是故事时间。那是故事时间。”好吧，如果你注意到15分25秒的时候，
Halstead and Warren both brought so much of their personal stuff. I know. Halstead said he was on a college tour with his father and they were visiting Williams College in Massachusetts. And the admissions office was a small house that had been converted into offices. And while Hall said it was waiting for his interview, he decided maybe he should run to the bathroom really quickly. So he went to the bathroom,
你可以透过约翰肩膀后面的门看到小孩子们。所以他们确实在那儿。小孩子存在的证据。小孩子存在的证据。另外，吉姆撞见一个男的在洗手间里的整条故事线，其实是基于现实生活中的真实时刻。这太棒了，珍娜，你一定要讲讲。来自我们的编剧，霍尔斯特德·沙利文（Halstead Sullivan）。
which he described as just a typical bathroom that you would find in any house. He opened the door and he said, quote, he was suddenly face to face with a man sitting on the toilet who said, hello. Yeah. Halstead said, I am so sorry. Close the door, went back to wait for his interview. A few minutes later, when he was escorted to his interview, the man from the toilet. No, no, no. toilet was his interviewer. No, no.
霍尔斯特德和沃伦都融入了大量他们个人的经历。我知道。霍尔斯特德说他当时和父亲一起去大学巡回参观，他们正在参观马萨诸塞州的威廉姆斯学院（Williams College）。招生办公室是一栋改建成办公室的小房子。正当霍尔斯特德在等面试时，他决定也许自己应该快步去一下洗手间。于是他去了洗手间，
No, no. Yes. Oh, my lord. Halstedt said he was only 17 at the time and he, like, couldn't get out of his head during the interview. It's all he could think about was that this was the man from the toilet. He said he assumed that he loved the interview so he didn't even end up applying to the school. Oh, he didn't even apply.
他将其描述为你在任何房子里都能见到的那种典型洗手间。他打开门，他说，原话是：“他突然与一个坐在马桶上的男人面面相觑，那个人说：‘你好。’”对。霍尔斯特德说：“我太抱歉了。”然后关上门，回到了等候面试的地方。几分钟后，当他被带去面试时，那个马桶上的男人——不，不，不。马桶上的男人就是他的面试官。不，不。
No, he just scratched it off his list. Oh. He said years later, he pitched it as a storyline on the office to which I said, I just love how you guys brought these real-life moments from your life, how they make their way onto the show. And he said, you know what? You make all kinds of confessions when it's midnight
不，不。是的。噢，天哪。霍尔斯特德说他当时只有17岁，他简直，在面试时满脑子都在想这件事。他脑子里想的全都是这正是那个坐在马桶上的男人。他说他觉得自己肯定把面试搞砸了，所以最后甚至没有申请这所学校。哦，他连申请都没递交！
and you're just trying to think of a story so you can go home. And I thought, what fun would it be to be in the writer's room at midnight, what am I? 11.45, it goes down. What is being told? What is being said so much?
对，他直接把它从名单上划掉了。哦。他说多年以后，他把这个当成一个故事灵感提议用在《办公室》里，对此我说：“我只是太喜欢你们把生活中这些真实时刻融入剧中的方式了。”而他说：“你知道吗？当夜里12点，你绞尽脑汁只想编出一个故事好让你能回家时，你会做出各种各样的坦白。”我想，如果在午夜的编剧室里会是多有趣的一幕啊，我当时是几点？11点45分，它就播出了。到底在讲什么？到底说了那么多什么？
Well, Michael has decided to go to the one man he thinks has all the answers. David Wallace. And he says he doesn't like him stopping by unannounced, but who does? Except today, David Wallace is like thrilled to see Michael. So happy. He answers the door. He's unshaven. His son is playing drums in the background.
好吧，迈克尔决定去找他认为拥有所有答案的那个人。大卫·华莱士（David Wallace）。他说他不喜欢别人不请自来，但谁又喜欢呢？不过今天，大卫·华莱士见到迈克尔时简直高兴极了。开心极了。他开门的时候还没刮胡子。他的儿子在背景里打着鼓。
And David's like, come on in! Let's have lunch! Amazing. At 13 minutes, 43 seconds, when you see that establishing shot of David Wallace's house, you'll recognize it. We've been there before in the show. Per Randy Cordray, we rented this house for the day, and it was in in Sino, California. Lady, did you just give us a location alert? Oh, I guess I did. Wow, well done. Now, look at me fast, facking, and location alerting.
大卫说：“快请进！我们一起吃午饭吧！”太惊人了。在13分43秒时，当你看到大卫·华莱士房子的那个建立镜头，你会认出来的。我们在剧里去过那里。据兰迪·科德雷所说，我们租下了这栋房子一天，它位于加利福尼亚州的恩西诺（Encino）。天呐，你刚才是不是泄露了拍摄地点？哦，我想我确实泄露了。哇，干得漂亮。现在，看我快速地、机敏地进行地点泄露。
What is happening? I don't know. Should I look through my digital clutter? Yes, please. All right, I will. Okay, I'll be excited. Next week, watch out. Jenna's digital clata. Tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick- I think I see in which with, is it whipped marshmallow?
这到底是怎么回事？我不知道。我该翻翻我的数字杂物箱吗？好，请吧。好吧，我会很期待的。下周，小心了。珍娜的数字杂物箱。滴答滴答滴答……我觉得我看到了……是奶油棉花糖吗？
It's marshmallow cream, like marshmallow fluff and peanut butter. Have you ever had this? It's called a fluffer nutter. What, it is. It's called a fluffer nutter. I'm sure that it is called that. It is called a fluffer nutter.
是棉花糖乳酪，类似于棉花糖松饼酱（marshmallow fluff）和花生酱。你吃过这个吗？这叫“弗拉弗纳特”（fluffer nutter）。什么，是的。这叫“弗拉弗纳特”。我敢肯定它就叫这个。它确实叫“弗拉弗纳特”。
I just saying you know what a fluffer is, right? A fluffer nutter? Get your mind out of the gutter, lady. I said fluffer is, right? A fluffer nutter? Get your mind out of that gutter, lady. I said fluffer nutter. I'm, it, I'm praying to mind. Earlier, that's what she said. I'm sorry, earlier you said the best weiner in Scranton, and I didn't say a word.
我只是说你知道“弗拉弗”（fluffer）是什么意思吧？“弗拉弗纳特”？女士，请把你的思想从阴沟里拉回来。我说的是“弗拉弗”（fluffer）是什么意思，对吧？“弗拉弗纳特”？女士，请把你的思想从那个阴沟里拉出来。我说的是“弗拉弗纳特”。我……我在克制自己。刚才，你说了“那是她说的”。对不起，刚才你说了“斯克兰顿最好的热狗（weiner）”，我可是一句话都没说。
I wanted to, and I said no, keep it professional, Kinsey. I'm sorry, go on. Okay. I've clearly not heard this term. Okay. Well, the first time I ever had a fluffer nutter was in Connecticut. What? What? What? I didn't laugh a single time. You said weiner. All ha ha ha ha! Ha ha ha ha! Alright, we have to pause while my friend gets it together. Okay, go ahead. You had a fluffernutter.
我很想说，但我告诉自己：别说了，保持专业，金斯利。对不起，你继续。好的。我显然没听过这个词。好吧。我第一次吃“弗拉弗纳特”是在康涅狄格州。什么？什么？什么？我一次都没笑。你刚才说了“热狗（weiner）”。哈哈哈哈！哈哈哈哈！好吧，我们得暂停一下，等我朋友恢复平静。好吧，你继续。你吃过“弗拉弗纳特”。
Letter and Cleveland, where were you, Connecticut? Connecticut! Connecticut. My first fluffernutter was in Connecticut. I was visiting family with the laborsteens. Sorry. I'm sorry. I have the only one. Sam, please.
信件和克利夫兰，你在哪儿，康涅狄格州？康涅狄格州！康涅狄格州。我的第一个“弗拉弗纳特”是在康涅狄格州。我和拉伯斯坦（Laborsteen）一家一起去探亲。抱歉。对不起。我是唯一一个……萨姆，拜托。
Oh my gosh. Cassie is fine. You got a fluffernetter. And can you have a whole family? With Warren and Paul laborsteens. Oh, God. Okay. I had to know more about the sandwich.
噢天哪。凯西没事。你吃了个“弗拉弗纳特”。而且你还能一整个家族都去？和沃伦还有保罗·拉伯斯坦一家。哦，天哪。好吧。我得了解更多关于这个三明治的信息。
It's delicious. It's marshmallow cream and peanut butter. Okay, I was like I've never heard of this. Is it an East Coast thing? And guess what? It is! Really? According to the internet, it's marshmallow cream and peanut butter, but marshmallow cream, one of the main ingredients of a fluffer nutter, was invented in the early 20th century. Archibald queryery invented a cream he called Marshmallow cream and Somerville Massachusetts in 1917. And during World War One, Emma Curtis published a recipe for what she called the Liberty Sandwich, which was
太好吃了。就是棉花糖乳酪和花生酱。好吧，我当时就想，我从来没听说过这个。这是美国东海岸特有的东西吗？你猜怎么着？还真是！真的吗？根据网上的说法，它是棉花糖乳酪和花生酱，不过棉花糖乳酪作为“弗拉弗纳特”的主要成分之一，是在20世纪初发明的。阿奇博尔德·奎里（Archibald Query）于1917年在马萨诸塞州萨默维尔（Somerville）发明了一种他称之为棉花糖乳酪的乳酪。而在第一次世界大战期间，埃玛·柯蒂斯（Emma Curtis）发表了一种她称之为“自由三明治”（Liberty Sandwich）的食谱，里面是
peanut butter and her snowflake Marshmallow cream on oat or barley bread, the recipe was published in a promotional booklet and sent to customers and may be the origin of the Fluffer Nutter Sandwich. I have used this marshmallow cream like when you make rice crispy treats. Of course. It's like a hack. It is.
花生酱和她自制的雪花棉花糖乳酪，夹在燕麦面包或大麦面包上。这个食谱发表在一本促销小册子里并发给顾客，这可能就是“弗拉弗纳特三明治”的起源。我用过这种棉花糖乳酪，比如当你制作米花糖（rice crispy treats）的时候。当然。这就像是个厨房小窍门。确实是。
You don't have to melt a bag of marshmallows. The sandwich made with peanut butter and marshmallow cream continued to be eaten but was not called a fluffernutter until 1960 when an advertising firm that was working with this company, Dirkie Moher, that owns marshmallow cream, thought it might be a more effective way to market the sandwich. The sandwich has close ties to New England and Massachusetts particularly Summerville. In fact Summerville holds an annual festival called What the Fluff. No. Okay. Got anything nasty you want to say about their festival, Juna? No. Sam is giggling. The festival incorporates music, visual
你不用去融化一整包棉花糖。用花生酱和棉花糖乳酪制作的三明治一直有人在吃，但直到1960年才被称为“弗拉弗纳特”——当时一家与拥有棉花糖乳酪的公司（德基·穆尔，Dirkie Moher）合作的广告公司认为，这可能是营销这种三明治更有效的方式。这个三明治与新英格兰地区特别是马萨诸塞州的萨默维尔有着密切的联系。事实上，萨默维尔每年都会举办一个名为“什么是松饼（What the Fluff）”的节日。不是吧。好吧。关于他们的节日，珍娜，你有什么刻薄的话想说吗？没有。萨姆在咯咯笑。这个节日包含音乐、视觉
arts, games, and a cooking contest based around fluff and fluffer nutters. And October 8th is National Fluffer Nutter Day. Wow, there you go. Here's what I'm wondering. When did the term fluffer come around? Does it predate or post date the advertising agencies naming of this sandwich? Well, it was named in the 60s. I'll let you go down that rabbit hole. I'll let you Google Fluffer Origin. I'm curious. I mean, you know, I feel like fluffers were around in the 70s.
艺术、游戏以及围绕松饼和“弗拉弗纳特”的烹饪比赛。而且10月8日是全国弗拉弗纳特日。哇，原来如此。以下是我的疑问。术语“弗拉弗”（fluffer）是什么时候出现的？它的出现时间是在广告公司给这个三明治命名之前还是之后？嗯，它是在60年代命名的。我就让你去钻这个牛角尖吧。我让你去谷歌搜索“弗拉弗的起源”。我很好奇。我是说，你知道的，我觉得“弗拉弗”在70年代就已经存在了。
were around in the 70s. So maybe Fluffernutter predates it. So it's just an unfortunate thing for the sandwich that there's another maybe meaning. And for the record, I'm giggling. You were familiar with a Fluffernutter, right? This is something you knew. The sandwich. Yeah, but you were not familiar with a bagel.
在70年代就已经存在了。所以也许“弗拉弗纳特”出现得更早。所以对于这个三明治来说，不幸的是它有另一个可能不太雅观的含义。为了记录在案，我在咯咯笑。你以前就知道“弗拉弗纳特”，对吧？这是你知道的东西。这个三明治。是的，但你以前并不知道百吉饼（bagel）。
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha. I was by this time. For the record, that's why I'm. No, no, no, no, for the record, I didn't know what a fluffernutter or a bagel was. At all, they were all East Coast things and I didn't know about them. I found out about a fluffernutter after I knew what a bagel was. Got it, got it, got it. I would love a segment where you just reveal foods that
哈哈哈哈。我到那个时候已经知道了。为了记录在案，这就是为什么我……不，不，不，不，为了记录在案，我当时根本不知道什么是“弗拉弗纳特”或百吉饼。它们全都是东海岸的东西，我以前根本不知道。我是在知道什么是百吉饼之后，才知道“弗拉弗纳特”的。明白了，明白了，明白了。我很想看一个环节，就是你专门揭晓那些
you came to know later in life. Well, clearly, you're coming to know a Fluffernutter later in life. I am. I didn't know about this sandwich. I know about a Fluffernutter before you did. Just put it on record. It sounds maybe gross, but does it taste good? It's so good. I want to put a sliced banana on it. Yeah, why not? No, but I'm sure you'd love it. I bet at that festival, they deep fried them too. At what the fluff? Yeah, a deep fried fluff or nutter. I bet it's good. Back to the episode, one of my favorite exchanges of dialogue happens in this kitchen. Okay. Rachel, David Wallace's wife, Wilson. Yes. This is so much about their relationship and what's going on in their marriage right now. She goes, hey, honey,
你后来才了解到的。好吧，显然，你也是后来才知道Fluffernutter三明治的。我是的。我之前不知道有这个三明治。我比你更早知道Fluffernutter。记录在案。听起来可能有点恶心，但它好吃吗？非常好吃。我想在上面放一盘切片香蕉。对啊，为什么不呢？不，但我确信你会喜欢它的。我敢打赌在那个节日上，他们还把它们深度油炸了。在哪个棉花糖节？对，油炸棉花糖花生酱三明治。我敢打赌很好吃。回到这集，我最喜欢的对话之一发生在这个厨房里。好的。大卫·华莱士的妻子雷切尔，威尔逊。是的。这很大程度上关于他们的关系以及他们目前婚姻中发生的事情。她说，嘿，亲爱的，
how's your day going? Did you do anything cool? He's like, no, sweetie, just sort of hung out. your day going, did you do anything cool?" He was like, uh, no sweetie, just sort of hung out. And she says, this is the line. This is it. I wrote it down as well. Oh, because I saw you had shoes on. So I didn't know if you did anything. Amazing. Amazing. Rachel Wallace was played by Jean Villapique. She was a member of Second City Improv group. She's done a ton of comedy. You may have seen her on Veepe, Key and Peel, Modern Family, Bojack Horseman. She's also a regular on AP Bio. I loved how she clocked the camera. She walked into her oh, hi, honey. She's also so happy to see Michael. Oh my gosh. What a switch.
今天过得怎么样？你做什么酷的事了吗？他说，没，甜心，就是随便逛逛。今天过得怎么样，你做酷的事了吗？他说，呃，没有，甜心，就是随便逛逛。然后她说，就是这句台词。就是这个。我也把它写下来了。哦，因为我看到你穿着鞋。所以我不知道你有没有做什么。太棒了。太棒了。雷切尔·华莱士由让·维拉皮克饰演。她是第二城市即兴喜剧团的成员。她演过大量的喜剧。你可能在《副总统》、《基尔和皮尔》、《摩登家庭》、《马男波杰克》中见过她。她也是《学园 Dub 乐》的常驻演员。我喜欢她向镜头打招呼的方式。她走进来说，哦，嗨，亲爱的。她看到迈克尔也很高兴。哦天哪。真是个大反转。
I know, right? At 14 minutes, 10 seconds, we see Teddy, David Wallace is sun playing the drums. He was played by Owen Daniels. And you guys remember him, he was in the cocktails episode in season three. Well, I remember talking to Susan Daniels about Owen's drumming. And she
我知道，对吧？在14分10秒，我们看到了大卫·华莱士正在打鼓的儿子泰迪。他由欧文·丹尼尔斯饰演。你们还记得他，他在第三季的鸡尾酒那一集里出现过。嗯，我记得和苏珊·丹尼尔斯聊起欧文打鼓的事。她
was just, you know, having some mom pride about what a good drummer he was. And then here it got to be on the show. I know. So cool. Well, Michael and David are going to sit in the hot tub. It's just so awkward. I mean, he says to his wife, we might go outside. Yeah, at 16 minutes, 55 seconds, Michael is wearing a t-shirt in the hot tub. And Jen Sillada said this was because Steve was in such good shape that they had to hide his physique because it would have been distracting. Oh my gosh.
只是，你知道的，为他是一个多么优秀的鼓手而感到身为母亲的骄傲。然后在这里他得以在节目中出演。我知道。太酷了。好了，迈克尔和大卫要坐在按摩浴缸里了。真是太尴尬了。我是说，他对他的妻子说，我们可能会去外面。是的，在16分55秒，迈克尔在按摩浴缸里穿着T恤。简·西拉达说这是因为史蒂夫的身材太好了，他们不得不隐藏他的体形，因为那会让人分心。哦天哪。
Yeah, but like, you'd think, how is Michael in such good shape? Michael has like a 12 pack. Yeah. She also said it felt like this really great way to highlight how different David Wallace was being, that like David Wallace is just shirtless and relaxed. Drinking a beer?
对，但是你会想，迈克尔的身材怎么会这么好？迈克尔好像有12块腹肌。是的。她还说，这感觉像是一种非常棒的方式，突显出大卫·华莱士变得多么不同，大卫·华莱士光着膀子，很放松。喝着啤酒？
Yes. In the middle of the day. And Michael would be made, like, it would be more awkward for Michael to be in a t-shirt. We got a fan catch from Megan B and Potsville, Pennsylvania. In the hot tub scene, David Wallace is drinking a youngling logger. And Michael is drinking a youngling black and tan. Fast fact from Megan B. Youngling is America's oldest brewery and began right where I am from in Potsville, Pennsylvania.
是的。在白天。而且迈克尔会觉得，迈克尔穿着T恤会更尴尬。我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州波茨维尔的梅根·B的粉丝爆料。在按摩浴缸的场景中，大卫·华莱士在喝鹰狮啤酒。而迈克尔在喝鹰狮黑啤。梅根·B的快讯。鹰狮是美国最古老的酿酒厂，始创于我老家宾夕法尼亚州波茨维尔。
I looked it up. It was founded in 1829. They are still brewing today. Megan would like to give a big shout out to the props department for yet again paying such close attention to detail by including a local beer that is most definitely found in many refrigerators in northeastern Pennsylvania. Nicely done, Phil, Shay. I know. Megan would also like us to know, Angela, that if we ever come to Scranton, the Jungling Brewery Tour is just about an hour away and it's really great. Maybe we can time that out and we'll hit the what the fluff festival and then go for a factory tour. I like it. Mm-hmm. Will I get through the what the fluff festival? I don't think you will. I think you're gonna fit someone. For Randy Cordray, the hot tub scene at 16 minutes 46 seconds was
我查了一下。它成立于1829年。他们今天仍在酿造。梅根想向道具部门大声致敬，感谢他们再次如此密切地关注细节，加入了一种当地的啤酒，这种啤酒绝对可以在宾夕法尼亚州东北部的许多冰箱里找到。干得好，菲尔·谢伊。我知道。梅根还想让我们知道，安吉拉，如果我们去斯克兰顿，鹰狮啤酒厂之旅大约只有一个小时的车程，而且真的很棒。也许我们可以算准时间，去参加棉花糖节，然后去参观工厂。我喜欢。嗯哼。我能挺过棉花糖节吗？我觉得你不行。我觉得你会跟人起冲突。对兰迪·科德雷来说，16分46秒的按摩浴缸场景
already there. We did not have to provide that. Hey! Hey there! We just used those people's hot tub. They did. Okay. Well, in this hot tub scene, Michael is trying to get David to like give him ideas on how to deal with Saber, but David is thinking about something else. He's thinking about a new company that he wants to start. It is a shop vac that will suck up kids' toys. Zzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzz That's a lot of told us that it was her mom that came up with the idea for suck it. Come on. Yes, Jen's a lot of mom had this idea. She thought it would be a very fun way to teach kids how to pick up their toys. That is adorable.
已经在那儿了。我们不必提供那个。嘿！嘿，你好！我们只是用了那些人的按摩浴缸。他们用了。好吧。在这个按摩浴缸场景中，迈克尔试图让大卫给他一些关于如何对付萨伯的建议，但大卫在想别的事情。他在想他想创办的一家新公司。那是一个可以吸走小孩子玩具的吸尘器。吸……这有很多告诉我们，是她妈妈想出了“吸它”的点子。得了吧。是的，简·西拉达的妈妈想出了这个主意。她认为这将是一种非常有趣的方式，来教孩子们如何收拾他们的玩具。太可爱了。
So when she needed an invention for David Wallace, she thought of her mom's idea. And she said she thought it was perfect because since he's been home with his kids more often, he was probably frustrated with seeing their toys everywhere. It felt very organic. But how adorable is that? So cute. Well, lady, I decided to Google how do you suck up toys? Okay. I found an article by Newsweek in March of 2022. It talked about a guy who built a real life sucket for Lego pieces. Wow. How cool is that?
所以当她需要为大卫·华莱士发明一个发明时，她想到了她妈妈的点子。她说她觉得这很完美，因为自从他更经常在家陪孩子以来，他可能对到处都是玩具感到沮丧。这感觉非常自然。但这是多么可爱啊！太可爱了。好吧，女士，我决定谷歌一下怎么把玩具吸进去？好的。我找到了《新闻周刊》2022年3的一篇文章。里面谈到一个家伙为乐高积木建造了一个现实生活中的“吸它”。哇。多酷啊！
His name is Maddie Benedetto. And he posted the video. It shows him using a custom vacuum to collect pieces of Lego on the floor. Here's the ad. I invented the Lego Succ-in, the world's first vacuum-powered Lego cleanup device that automatically sorts each brick by its individual size. This vibrant cleaning accessory features a multi-stage chamber that magnetically separates for quick organization of your favorite toy bricks.
他的名字叫马蒂·贝内代托。他发布了视频。视频显示他使用定制吸尘器收集地板上的乐高积木。广告是这样的。我发明了乐高吸尘器，世界上第一个由真空驱动的乐高清理装置，它能根据单个尺寸自动分类每一块积木。这款充满活力的清洁配件具有一个多级腔室，可以磁性分离，以便快速整理你最喜欢的玩具积木。
The high-such-in vacuum will ensure every brick is sucked up from your floors and swiftly deposited into the clear tube, as each Lego piece cascades down and gets started into their different sizes. So when things get messy, just suck it. How about that? Wow. How many Legos have you stepped on? It's so painful. But how are you not sucking up everything on the floor? Like how is there not also a gold fish in there maybe? Oh, or a Cheerio. Exactly, right.
高吸力真空吸尘器将确保每一块积木都被从你的地板上吸走，并迅速存入透明管中，随着每一块乐高积木倾泻而下，并根据不同的大小进行分类。所以当事情变得一团糟时，只要吸一下。怎么样？哇。你踩过多少块乐高？太痛苦了。但是你怎么能不把地上的所有东西都吸进去呢？比如里面怎么可能没有一条金鱼呢？哦，或者一粒喜瑞尔麦片。完全正确，对吧？
I don't know. You have to have a clean Lego space. This is the thing. This is kind of the problem with David's invention, which is that, you know, yes, you're gonna suck up the toys, but how do you avoid sucking up everything else? You just suck it.
我不知道。你必须有一个干净的乐高空间。就是这样。这正是大卫的发明的问题所在，也就是说，是的，你会吸走玩具，但你如何避免吸走其他一切？你只要吸一下。
You just suck it. You just suck it. Well, Michael's gonna leave David Wallace's. sucking up everything else. You just suck it. You just suck it. You just suck it. Well, Michael's gonna leave David Wallace's, he's so defeated. He says very few things would make him say no to working with David Wallace, but suck it is one of them. And then I love this shot of Michael slowly pulling away
你只要吸一下。你只要吸一下。好吧，迈克尔要离开大卫·华莱士家了，他太受打击了。他说极少的事情会让他拒绝和大卫·华莱士合作，但“吸它”是其中之一。然后我喜欢这个镜头，迈克尔慢慢地把车开走
and David Wallace is sort of like lumbering down the driveway toward the car. Like kind of like a zombie. It's a zombie movie. Jen's lot of said this shot was John's idea and I think it is some foreshadowing for a quiet place. No, really. I really do. It felt very horror movie to me. Right after this creepy goodbye with David Wallace, would have come the final accounting scene in the runner that got deleted. Here's how it wraps up. Accounting area, interior office. Angela's looking over Kevin's work.
而大卫·华莱士像僵尸一样蹒跚着穿过车道走向汽车。就像僵尸电影一样。简·西拉达说这个镜头是约翰的主意，我认为这是对《寂静之地》的某种伏笔。不，真的。我真的这么觉得。这对我来说感觉非常像恐怖电影。在这个毛骨悚然的告别大卫·华莱士之后，本该是那个被删掉的最终会计场景。结局是这样的。会计区，办公室内部。安吉拉正在查看凯文的工作。
Angela, who did this? Oscar shakes his head. Kevin, it's possible I did it on my own. Angela, no, it's not. That is the one thing that is not possible. How did this happen? Kevin, I did it. Angela's size confused and walks away. Just missing Todd, who approaches with Kevin's adding machine.
安吉拉，这是谁干的？奥斯卡摇摇头。凯文，可能是我自己干的。安吉拉，不，不可能。那是唯一不可能的事。这是怎么发生的？凯文，我干的。安吉拉叹了口气，一脸困惑地走开了。正好错过托德，他带着凯文的加法机走过来。
Kevin looks nervous. Todd, you left this on my desk. Kevin, thanks. Todd and Oscar ad lib hellos. And Todd leaves. Kevin, don't tell Angela. Oscar, I won't. Kevin, I didn't just let him do the work.
凯文看起来很紧张。托德，你把这个忘在我的桌子上了。凯文，谢谢。托德和奥斯卡即兴打招呼，托德离开了。凯文，别告诉安吉拉。奥斯卡，我不会的。凯文，我不仅仅是让他干活。
I learned stuff. Please don't tell her. Oscar, I said I won't. Kevin looks nervous. Oscar looks up at him. Oscar. He trained me when I started here. Kevin, really? Oscar nods and Kevin smiles. What a sweet ending to that story. I know and who is Todd at Vance for Friguration. I mean, it kind of sounded like maybe Todd used to work at Dunder Mithlin. I don't know. I feel like Todd is training people.
我学到了东西。请别告诉她。奥斯卡，我说我不会的。凯文看起来很紧张。奥斯卡抬头看着他。奥斯卡。我刚来这里时是他培训我的。凯文，真的吗？奥斯卡点点头，凯文笑了。这个故事的结局多么温馨。我知道，范斯制冷公司的托德是谁？我的意思是，听起来好像托德曾经在邓德米弗林工作过。我不知道。我觉得托德在培训人。
Yeah. Anyway, I thought that was sort of sweet. Well, speaking of sweet, something we haven't talked about is that cutie pie scene at reception with Andean Aaron, where they're both not asking each other out on a date. It's a totally adorable scene, but if I'm being honest, I was very distracted by the fact that Pam's watercolor is back on the wall. It's all I could see. It's all I could see. I was just so delighted. Michael's gonna return and he's gonna make a toast. He's brought a lot of orange juice.
是的。不管怎样，我觉得那挺温馨的。好吧，说到温馨，我们还没有谈论的一件事是前台安迪和艾琳的那个可爱场景，他们俩都没有约对方出去。这是一个完全可爱的场景，但如果说实话，我很分心，因为潘的水彩画又挂回墙上了。我只能看到那个。我只能看到那个。我只是太高兴了。迈克尔要回来了，他要敬酒。他带了很多橙汁。
I guess an honor of Tallahassee. Florida. Yeah. Oranges. He makes his toast. It's not really a toast, but everyone takes a big swig and they're like, little. Yeah, I mean, have you ever had orange juice out of like an aluminum container? Little tangy. Yeah, I mean, it goes right into your teeth just like they talk about. But you know what? I don't think that a lot of people are putting their orange juice into metal containers. You know, it's really meant to be a water vessel. Like that you said, vessel. Thank you.
我猜这算塔拉哈西的荣誉。佛罗里达。对。橙子。他做了祝酒。其实也不算祝酒，但每个人都大大地喝了一口，然后觉得，有点。对，我是说，你有没有用铝制容器喝过橙汁？有点刺激。对，我是说，它就像他们说的那样，直接刺激你的牙齿。但你知道吗？我觉得没多少人会把橙汁装进金属容器里。你知道，那其实是用来装水的容器。就像你说的，容器。谢谢你。
It's a water vessel. It is. Well, I guess this toast means that Michael is going to stay. He's going to stick it out at Saber. Yes, he's going to, I guess, have to abide by all these new rules that he hates. No YouTube for Michael at work. I don't know how that's gonna go. The episode ends with David Wallace and his son jamming out to a song that he's written called
这是一个水容器。确实是。好吧，我想这个祝酒意味着迈克尔要留下来了。他要在萨博公司坚持下去。是的，他打算，我想，不得不遵守所有他讨厌的新规。迈克尔在工作时不能用YouTube。我不知道这会怎么样。剧集在大卫·华莱士和他儿子一起弹奏他写的一首歌中结束，这首歌叫
Suck It. Let's listen to it. What you gonna do? You gonna take out your socket and your socket! Suck it! Take out your socket and your socket! Suck it! Yeah! Suck it! Yeah! Yeah!
吸出来。我们来听听。你要怎么办？你要拿出你的吸管和你的吸管！吸出来！拿出你的吸管和你的吸管！吸出来！耶！吸出来！耶！耶！
Take out my socket, Evo! Suck it! Yeah! Yeah! Take out my socket, Evo! Suck it! Yeah! Oh, and Daniel's on the drum. Oh, man.
拿出我的吸管，伊沃！吸出来！耶！耶！拿出我的吸管，伊沃！吸出来！耶！哦，丹尼尔在打鼓。哦，天哪。
We got a fan question from Donna in Newport, New Virginia. Please tell us everything about the Suck It Song at the end of the episode, How Much Was Improvized. I will tell you, Donna, the lyrics to suck it were written by Warren and Hallstead. These guys really were our go-to guys for song lyrics. And then I reached out to Andy Buckley who plays David Wallace. He said that Warren and Hallstead facts him the lyrics the night before. Old tech alert Angela facts. Yeah, they faxed him the lyrics the night before. Old tech alert, Angela, faxed.
我们收到了来自新弗吉尼亚州纽波特的唐娜的粉丝提问。请告诉我们关于剧集结尾那首“吸出来”之歌的一切，有多少是即兴发挥的。我来告诉你，唐娜，“吸出来”的歌词是由沃伦和霍尔斯特德写的。这些人真的是我们歌词的御用人选。然后我联系了饰演大卫·华莱士的安迪·巴克利。他说沃伦和霍尔斯特德在前一天晚上把歌词传真给他了。旧科技警报，安吉拉传真。对，他们前一天晚上把歌词传真给他了。旧科技警报，安吉拉，传真。
Yeah. They faxed them. He went over them that night. He went over them at lunch the next day. That's when he was able to kind of fiddle around on a keyboard. Andy said he only knew about three chords on a keyboard. But he did his best.
对。他们传真过来的。他那天晚上看了一遍。第二天午饭时他又看了一遍。就在那时，他得以在键盘上胡乱弹奏了一番。安迪说他在键盘上只知道大约三个和弦。但他尽力了。
They did not shoot this until the very end of the day. They only had three minutes before they went into overtime. Three minutes. Yes. No messing up. Yes. He said it all came together when Owen started playing the drums. It was kind of a magic moment. They got it in three takes.
他们直到一天快结束时才拍摄这个。在他们超时之前只有三分钟。三分钟。是的。不能搞砸。是的。他说当欧文开始打鼓时，一切都融合在一起了。这有点像个神奇的时刻。他们拍了三次就过了。
He said that the whole shoot day was a total blast. He loved John as a director. He said John just had tons of positive energy. And that John and Jens a lot of work so well together. He's sort of remembered that. Someone would do a take and then you'd see them kind of huddle and giggle and then they would come over with some great idea. That's my memory to. Same. And he said that inevitably. And he said that inevitably if he is walking through an airport or some public place, there is always someone who yells out suck it. He also said that he and Zach Woods are now on an
他说整个拍摄日非常开心。他很喜欢作为导演的约翰。他说约翰有着满满的正能量。而且约翰和詹很多工作都配合得很好。他依稀记得这一点。有人拍完一条后，你会看到他们聚在一起咯咯笑，然后他们就会带着某个绝妙的主意走过来。这也是我的记忆。一样。而且他说，不可避免地。而且他说，不可避免地，如果他走过机场或某个公共场所，总会有人大喊“吸出来”。他还说他和扎克·伍兹现在正在出演一部
HBO comedy called Avenue 5 and it films in London. Amazing. He said they were in London for four months before the pandemic in the summer of 2019 and they just went back this past fall in 2021. He said that the difference between people stopping the two of them before the pandemic and after the pandemic is striking. He said clearly a lot of people binge the office during the pandemic. He's getting way more suckits. Wait, wait, well, I hope that's a good thing. I think so. Well, that is the Saber episode. Well, before we go, I
HBO喜剧叫《第五大道》，在伦敦拍摄。太棒了。他说在2019年夏天的疫情之前，他们在伦敦待了四个季度，然后刚刚在2021年去年秋天回去。他说疫情前和疫情后人们拦住他们两个人的区别非常惊人。他说显然很多人在疫情期间疯狂刷了《办公室》。他收到更多“吸出来”的呼喊了。等等，等等，好吧，我希望这是件好事。我也这么觉得。好吧，这就是萨博那一集。在我们离开之前，我
thought we could end this episode with a few final thoughts from John about what directing this episode meant to him. This show was my film school. I mean, I was a waiter before I got the show. I had zero experience in this business, in anything, acting, writing, directing, producing any of that stuff. And there it was, right in front of me, I was somehow lucky enough to drop right into the most immense pool of talent that I could ever ask for.
觉得我们可以用约翰关于执导这一集对他的意义的一些最后想法来结束这一集。这部剧是我的电影学院。我是说，在加入这部剧之前我是一个服务员。我在这个行业里零经验，不管是表演、写作、导演、制作还是其他任何事情。然后它就这样出现在我面前，我居然足够幸运，直接掉进了我能要求的最大的人才池里。
From that insane group of people that we had as our writers, a group of people that hadn't been assembled like that in a long, long time, I guess, and, you know, in a lot of ways, probably hasn't been assembled since. So from writing, I got to understand what it meant to not only write well, but to have fun with it and to have this drive to do something great. I remember going up to the writer's rooms every now and again, if I had a break between scenes or something
从我们作为编剧的那群疯狂的人来看，这是一群很久很久没有这样聚集在一起的人，我想，而且，在很多方面，可能从那以后就再也没有聚集在一起了。所以从写作方面，我开始理解什么不仅是写得好，而且是享受其中，并有动力去做一些伟大的事情。我记得每隔一段时间就会去编剧室，如果我在两场戏之间有休息时间或者别的什么
and watch them all come up with an idea. And the idea was almost like you could visualize a balloon in the air, and 12 to 14 people were making sure it didn't touch the ground before they had investigated every single possibility of how to make it work and how to make a joke work or an idea work. And even if it didn't end up working, they still put it on a different board that was like,
看着他们所有人想出一个主意。那个主意几乎就像你能想象空气中有一个气球，12到14个人在确保它不落地，直到他们研究了如何让它行之有效、如何让一个笑话或一个主意行之有效的每一个可能性。即使最后没有成功，他们还是会把它放到另一块板上，上面写着，
well, it's not working today, but maybe it'll work again on another day. And if it did work, they all worked together to try to figure out how it would best be used in this show. So writing wise, there I was, front row seats in the greatest room I could be. Visually, I had no idea what even a camera was.
好吧，今天行不通，但也许改天又能行了。如果真的行得通，他们会一起想办法在剧中如何最好地利用它。所以就写作而言，我当时就坐在最好的房间里的第一排座位。视觉上，我甚至不知道什么是摄像机。
I didn't know the difference between lenses were. I didn't know what type of cameras did what. But I remember there again, the office was shot single camera. It was one of the first shows to be done and like that in a long time. And so we were shooting the show like a movie. So I got to pick the brain of Randall and Matt and all these hugely talented people who would explain to me everything from lenses to the aesthetic and lighting and all these different things that I had absolutely no idea about. After Dr. Dr. King's saber I used to hang out with Dave Rogers and watch him cut all these different episodes. I'd pop in and see how he was making all these scenes work, how he was rearranging story, how he was taking air out of a moment
我不知道镜头之间的区别是什么。我不知道什么类型的摄像机能做什么。但我再次记得，《办公室》是用单摄像机拍摄的。它是很久以来第一批采用这种方式拍摄的节目之一。所以我们像拍电影一样在拍摄这部剧。因此，我有幸向兰德尔、马特以及所有这些才华横溢的人请教，他们向我解释了一切，从镜头到美学、灯光以及所有这些我完全一无所知的事情。在博士...博士金的萨博之后，我经常和戴夫·罗杰斯在一起，看他剪辑所有这些不同的剧集。我会插话看他是如何让所有这些场景发挥作用的，他是如何重新安排故事的，他是如何从一个时刻抽离空气
to make it work so much stronger. So really at the end of the day, I certainly would not be writing and directing at all if it wasn't for this show. I just, I wouldn't have had the confidence to do it. So I guess what I'm trying to say is, I owe absolutely everything to this show. Directing this episode was so very special and I will truly never forget it.
来让它变得更有力量。所以归根结底，如果不是因为这部剧，我肯定不会从事编剧和导演工作。我只是，我不会有信心去做的。所以我想我要说的是，我绝对把一切都归功于这部剧。执导这一集非常特别，我真的永远不会忘记。
Thank you for having me on the show. I was so excited to come back and have me back again. But again, like I said, slow down. We need more of this podcast, please. John Krasinski, we love you. Love you so much, John. That was so generous of you. You shared so much with us.
谢谢你邀请我上节目。我很高兴能回来，并再次邀请我。但正如我所说，慢点。我们需要更多这样的播客，拜托。约翰·卡拉辛斯基，我们爱你。非常爱你，约翰。你太慷慨了。你和我们分享了那么多。
And I just loved hearing your voice. Same. Also want to give a big thank you to Yaki Margolese for that amazing Beach Boys parody. You can find him on Twitter and Instagram at Yaki Margolese and you can listen to his music online anywhere that you get your music like Spotify, Apple Music, iTunes, etc. I also want to say thank you to Joya Balfour for sharing with us what NBC digital was up to and to Randy Cordray and Warren Lee
我只是很喜欢听你的声音。我也是。还要非常感谢雅基·马尔戈利斯创作了那首精彩的海滩男孩恶搞歌曲。你可以在Twitter和Instagram上通过@YakiMargolese找到他，你可以在任何获取音乐的在线平台上听他的音乐，比如Spotify、Apple Music、iTunes等。我还要感谢乔亚·巴尔福与我们分享NBC数字部门在做的事情，以及感谢兰迪·科德雷和沃伦·李
Resteen and Halsted Sullivan. Thank you, everyone. We will see you next week. I hope you enjoy a fluffer matter this week. I'm going to have one. Please do. I will. Oh, on gluten-free bread. Yay.
雷斯廷和霍尔斯特德·沙利文。谢谢大家。我们下周见。希望大家这周能喜欢一个绒毛三明治。我要吃一个。请吃吧。我会的。哦，用无麸质面包。耶。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Keeper and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is rubber tree by Creed Ratten. For add free versions of Office Ladies, go to stitur premium dot com. For a free one versions of Office Ladies, go to Stitupremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitupremium, use code Office. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、詹妮弗·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基珀，副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·拉滕的《橡胶树》。要获取无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问stiturpremium.com。要获取免费一个月的试用版，请使用代码Office。本集尚无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。